Hello Freak bitches.
That's right.
We'll back.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by legal zoom.
Legal Zoom is a,
a company that I love and respect,
but I'm not going to read their copy.
This is why,
cause I'm going to read their copy to you and you're going to understand right
away.
Why wouldn't just read their copy?
America was built by innovators and dreamers.
People like Thomas Edison and Henry Ford laid the foundation for our country.
Feel free to use different names.
I would use Ron,
Jeremy,
and uh,
Oliver Stone.
I would use Joe Rogan.
Oh,
Moshi.
So sweet.
These days.
It's innovators and entrepreneurs all around us.
I think this country was founded by savages trying to escape,
escape a dictatorship.
But what the fuck do I know?
I have rudimentary grasp of history.
They were innovative savages.
Yeah.
They're kind of innovator where they,
uh,
you know,
wanting to be free with had slaves.
It was a new thing.
Uh,
this month,
legal zoom celebrates innovation by helping you launch your dream.
Not that,
by the way,
I should just clarify.
Not that I'm anything against pioneers or pilgrims.
Oh yeah.
You might get some pioneers blogging about too.
They get fucking pistols.
Pilgrims,
they get nutty.
That's the one time will they'll use a computer.
Yeah.
They fire it up with their water wheel.
They get online.
That's it.
They start splitting wood.
This is going to be a long session.
I'm gonna need a lot of wood.
That's back when America online was only the 13 colonies,
a o,
l I fucking bobcat.
Goldthwait still as AOL.
He gave me his email the other day was an AOL email.
He doesn't fuck around,
man.
Yeah,
well,
they got hacked recently.
There was some issue recently.
Somebody probably just realized that,
oh,
they're here.
Let's hack them.
They were even know they were able to break into the personal information of
senior citizens across the land.
You've got mail.
Remember that?
That was good,
man.
Remember that?
That was awesome.
Until you got mail every fucking second of every day.
You know if you mentioned,
if you had that shit today,
you've got mail,
you've got to fucking Jesus fucking Christ and weirdly enough,
all of this was the copy from legal zoom.com yes,
exactly.
The copy this month,
legal zoom celebrates innovation by helping you launch your dream.
Here's what legal zoom actually is.
This is my version of it.
Legal Zoom is an awesome way to take care of legal shit at home from the privacy
of your own apartment or house and you could do it drunk and naked and no one
can stop you and it's legal and if you can,
if you're a functional drunk.
I said,
do it man.
Fuck it.
Fuck the system man.
But what you can do with legal zoom is take care of a lot of shit that you would
ordinarily have to go to a law office for.
Things like incorporating,
forming an LLC to start a business.
You can get that done cheaper at legal zoom like you can incorporate starting at
99 bucks and no trips don't have to go anywhere.
Don't have to make an appointment to be somewhere at a very specific time.
You can do it in the middle of the night when the world is asleep
and if you panic,
legal zoom can set you up with a third party independent attorney.
Cause I know that is a big issue with a lot of folks.
You know,
you don't feel like this is all right and does it.
And some people like,
you know,
it comes something dealing with the law and get very touchy and rightly so.
It's,
you know,
the worst case scenarios,
they could lock you in fucking cage.
That's not good.
Anyway,
celebrate innovation with legal zoom through the end of June and get a special
price on trademark copyright or
provisional patent applications.
That's a weird word.
You never see that provisional
provisional application for patents.
It's say,
uh,
what does that just to file a provisional patent applications?
I think it's,
if you have an idea you filed for a provisional patent before they actually
grant you a pattern so that nobody else can take that technology.
And so it was my idea.
I think that's exactly what it is.
I don't know why it's provisional.
I don't even know what provisional means.
I would think of provisional as being like a locational thing.
You know,
like it's a provisional jurisdiction.
What's like a pro,
you know,
we'll let you do it,
but we have a couple of provisions.
Right.
I was thinking of as a province,
you know,
I'm thinking of it in the wrong way.
Well
I'm thinking of is like a province like provisional being like the province of
Quebec provincial.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
I'm saying it wrong.
I have an idea.
Right.
Provision is a provision,
not a cat food that the dog can eat.
Awesome.
Like it's caffeine and dog food.
It's just one fit.
What are you calling it?
Provisional Kibble.
Provisional Food for your fucking pen.
Where did that come from?
Because my cat eats my dog.
Oh,
you want to cut my cash?
Well your dog's probably,
yeah.
Better off than the cat is cause cats.
If you,
if you only fed your cat dog food,
the cat would probably get sick.
Yeah.
That's why you can't have vegan cats.
Like even people who are like hardcore vegans,
they eventually give up and started giving their cats animal protein because the
cats get really sick cats or an animal that needs almost entirely protein.
I'm willing to kill my cat in the name of animal rights too.
That's dope.
Yeah.
Anyway,
uh,
legal zoom,
go to legalzoom.com they have an a plus from the better business bureau,
so wow.
That's all you need to know.
But celebrate innovation with legal zoom through the end of June and get a
special price again on trademark copyright or provisional patent applications by
using the referral code.
Rogan at checkout.
That's legal.
zoom.com legal zoom provides legal help through independent attorneys and self
help,
but they are not a law firm.
Okay Bitch.
So don't be suing legal zoom cause that shit will turn out ugly for you.
You son.
Yeah.
Like who's going to do it as a negative thing against him on the better business
bureau?
I'd be scared as fuck the legal zoom knows a thing or two about their rights and
how to fuck you right back,
Mr.
Anyway,
legal,
zoom.com using code word Brogan,
save yourself some money.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that is o n n I t if you are to
get in shape,
if you're looking for home exercise equipment,
if you're looking for healthy foods and supplements that you could eat post
workout we got you covered at on it on it is what we call it human optimization
website.
Uh,
what that means is when we find anything that benefits the body,
the brain,
anything new,
strength and conditioning equipment that's out,
things that people are using to help their endurance or their immune system.
Shroom tech immune is one of those that we take a,
we have a for sale and uh,
it works in a very interesting way.
Um,
similar to what I'm Doctor Rhonda Patrick was talking about on the podcast the
other day,
she was,
uh,
if you haven't listened to that one fascinating stuff,
I still have to go over it again and take notes and start googling shit because
whenever she's on,
she's,
she's so smart.
She just rattles off information at this ridiculous pace.
And you have to go back and try to decipher what,
what makes sense about all of it,
but the way shrimp tech works,
all the supplements,
whether it's shrimp tack or whether it's Alpha brain or anything else.
If you go to the almond website,
that's o,
n n I t and click on the link for any of the supplements.
There's a very detailed overview of everything that the supplement does,
what it's all based on.
Then there is a research link.
If you click on the research link,
it will show you all the clinically tested aspects of each and every product
that we sell.
Also,
if you,
even if you go through all that,
and even if you,
you try it and you go,
you know what,
this,
I don't like this shit.
This is bullshit.
You get 100% of your money back.
If you send nothing,
you don't have to send in the bottle of pills.
You don't have to do anything for the first 30 pills.
You have 90 days.
Try Your Alpha brain,
try shroom tech.
If you don't believe in it,
get your money back.
You don't have to return anything.
No one's trying to fuck you.
All were trying to do is sell you shit that we use all the things that we sell
at Alpha brain,
at a on it rather,
whether it's Alpha brain,
whether it's a strength and conditioning equipment like the kettle bells or the
weight vest.
I use all that shit.
And uh,
I think that it's all beneficial.
There's science behind all of it and there's a history of use,
whether it's a history of use of the supplements,
whether it's the nootropics or whether it's a shroom tech,
which is a UN,
well there's two,
there's one for the immune system and shroom tech sport,
which is an endurance based supplement.
Both of them are based on a different types of mushrooms that have been shown to
have an excellent effect on oxygen absorption.
The shroom tech,
uh,
immune one is a pretty fascinating,
but the shroom tech sport one is,
is really obvious.
Like if you use it,
you will,
you will feel a big difference in the amount of energy have.
It's like you get an extra gear.
All of is explained way better than I'm going to be able to do it@onnit.com but
the key ingredient is a quarter steps mushroom,
cordyceps,
sinensis and cordyceps.
Sinensis is a fascinating mushroom.
Uh,
that's several thousand years ago,
high in the mountains of Tibet.
Herdsmen noticed that when their herds would graze on this certain fungus,
they were noticeably more lively and energetic.
All of it is explained@onnit.com use the code word Rogan and you will save 10%
off any and all supplements.
You got any shows coming up?
Anything
a comic con 2014 oh Jesus.
Louise's is that in San Diego,
California,
where you have to hide your weed?
No doubt.
I had to do that.
I was there all weekend h hiding my,
we'd buy a comic con.
We were doing kill Tony Funder,
pussy and a comedy show the following day.
Beautiful,
glorious.
And if you could go to legal zoom,
you could change your name was one of the services and you can buy on it and
then return it and then change your name again by more on it.
Return it.
You could just keep on changing your name and getting free on it.
You retarded.
Why would you even say that?
You don't know Jesus Christ.
That would cost so much money to change her name that many times.
I don't think it would.
If you could save like $100 on it,
there's a lot of idiots who would do anyway.
Um,
what else is going on?
Uh,
killed Tony.
No.
Um,
Thunderpussy this Friday,
this Friday.
Thunderpussy and you're going to be doing,
I'm going to be doing it and I won't be sober.
There's only one way to do Thunderpussy.
That's right.
You gotta be fucked up.
So I'm going to take a lot of coconut water that day.
Get a lot of electrolytes in my system and let the party begin and that's going
to sell out.
It's a little tiny ass room,
so that's only like 80 seats.
Um,
the next gigs that I have on the road,
I'm at the Orpheum theater in Vancouver on June 13th with Brian Cowen and Tony
Hinchcliffe.
Oh,
suck at Jesus.
And you could find the information for all of that@joerogan.net.
All my tour dates and all that stuff is up there.
All right.
Motion caches here.
Well,
I fall.
Go round.
I got dates.
Please fuck with some dots.
Yeah,
man.
That shit out.
And he's hilarious comedian.
Yeah,
come see me.
I'll be at Johnny Brenda's in Philadelphia on June the third and uh,
also be in Fort Lauderdale and Connecticut at the comics thing.
Their choices.
Two very brave choice.
It's bad.
It's brave.
Wonderful,
brave.
It's sort of like a,
it's a balance sheet.
And then I'm going to boat party.biz.
That's a comedy show on a,
on a cruise.
So everybody go there and go to my scope.
Thrown anybody overboard as a joke.
That's my closer because the cap 10 overboard and we try and get home.
All right.
Boom.
Click the loop.
Oh,
what did you give up your website?
Oh yeah.
Moshe kasher.com the only important one is Philadelphia.
Come see me there.
Go see him in Philly.
You fucked.
Hit The music
experience.
Oh,
sweet baby.
Lebus Moshe Kasher.
Sir.
Welcome to the blackout.
Oh Man.
Thank you.
I'm so glad to be here.
Thank you for asking me.
I was watching you last night.
I watched you on set list.
Oh really?
That was really fun.
Thanks man.
Set List was just very similar in a lot of ways to uh,
Thunderpussy.
What's Thunderpussy all about?
Tony puts,
he's a podcast
where you go on stage and you do none of your material.
You go onstage and the audience will yell out topics and you just riff from
there and try to do a whole set based on their suggestions.
That sounds like exactly in my wheelhouse.
Yeah,
it's my sweet spot.
The difference between settlers,
is that where they write it down on a wall or is that list?
It's on a screen.
No,
no,
no.
They put it up on a screen.
Like you're on stage,
you know,
they introduce you,
you go out there,
you say hi to everybody and then there's a little screen and on the screen is
like,
he,
he had a great one.
It was a,
I fuck the elderly so that you don't have to,
and he went to this great.
He is,
he's right here.
This is another guy that's really hilarious thing about him.
You know,
he was working with Milton Berle back in the 20s.
That was his catch line.
He would say,
I fucked the elderly and the audience would go,
so you don't have to,
it was really funny man.
I really enjoyed it.
I really enjoyed it,
man.
It's uh,
you know,
I've,
I've heard about you for a while,
you know,
so it was nice to meet you when we did that.
I'm Ari Shapiro show or is not happening.
You are very funny that evening as well.
Thank you very much.
That's true though.
It's true.
Oh,
thank you.
Yeah,
that's how I just a I love that there's still comics out there that I haven't
met.
There's still hilarious.
Like I just still never met big Jay Oakerson.
He is hilarious.
Keep hearing great things about him that night.
Yeah.
I didn't get a chance to like sit down and talk to them.
Um,
and then,
uh,
I didn't need,
um,
well I've met him but junior stopcock I never remember hung out with him.
I need to hang out.
That dude looks,
I'd never met him and he looks like a serial killer though.
It looks awesome.
I love his look in a good way.
I hope you don't take offense junior.
Do you like the way serial killers look?
Yeah,
yeah.
Actually when I used to have it,
when I had a day job,
I was really,
I'm really in the serial killers.
I mean like I like to Google them and check out their vibes
and I,
I was at the,
I worked in a cubicle for a while and I was googling serial killers and the way
that it worked,
that was a sign language interpreter for a long time.
And uh,
the way that it would work,
because I would work at,
we work in a cubicle and I'd be somebody to cubicle over.
You were interpreting over the Internet over webcams.
Wow.
This,
this is a long story,
but if you needed help,
if you need backup,
you would click a little button and then whoever was available would leave their
thing and come over to your cubicle,
sit with you,
help you translate.
Because sometimes the people would pop up,
wouldn't be easy to understand.
They'd be gnarled.
They missing fingers or retarded or you would need some extra help.
And so I just for like three hours had this like just computer monitor of like
famous serial killers tab over Northern California serial killers tab over how
do I become a serial killer tech now.
But anyway,
it was pretty popular.
That's not good sleep.
And watching sent CNN all weekend,
I'm guessing.
What?
Oh,
about homeboy.
Yeah.
This
which you don't know homeboy is this kid and San Diego or in Santa Barbara or
rather one on a killing spree.
And didn't it wasn't he targeting women targeting like girls wouldn't have sex
with them?
No,
I'm not going to lie.
I watched it.
It's pretty intense.
I want to get that guy's juice in my head.
Yeah.
You know,
there's,
I posted
something on Twitter and I,
I should probably clarify after I posted it,
it was an article,
um,
about how many serial killers in mass shootings,
mass shooters have,
uh,
a history of psychiatric medication.
You know,
and it's,
it's,
it's staggering.
You know,
it's like something like more than 90% of all these,
uh,
mass killers are on Ssri or coming off of SSRS.
And,
um,
I,
I definitely don't think that the SSRS or killing people,
don't get me wrong,
I don't think that ssrs or bad for you,
and obviously I'm not qualified to judge.
Um,
I have zero medical background.
I barely understand vitamins.
I barely understand what the fuck I'm talking about.
But I think that you got to look at the possibility that something that makes
everything okay for you.
It's also going to make everything okay as far as like your actions,
like things that you do.
And I think if you have anger and you have psychotic thoughts and you have,
you know,
a lot of like frustration at the world and something comes along that makes her
actions.
Okay.
I think there's a lot of ways there's gotta be some sort of correlation there.
I'm not saying that,
you know,
people should stop taking antidepressants because we both know guys who have
taken it and it's fucking changed their life and all of a sudden they're cool to
be around.
They're like way happier.
I mean,
anything that makes you way happy I'm totally down for,
but these,
there is a connection.
It's pretty undeniable.
It's not,
it doesn't necessarily mean it's causal.
Like the taking the medication has caused these people to act in this way.
Not necessarily,
but I have a good friend that was murdered by someone who was on
antidepressants,
you know,
so it's,
uh,
it's real shit.
I Dunno,
isn't it?
I mean,
isn't the idea it becomes a chicken or egg kind of conversation,
right.
Because if you're crazy,
odds are,
you're going to have been referred to take some Ssri.
Exactly.
Have you ever been on them?
No.
I have.
Yeah.
When I was a kid and that was a very young,
when I was 1213 years old,
I was on,
that's how that seems really young.
It was real.
I was,
yeah,
it was a,
it was a big mess,
but I felt it in a bad way,
sort of coursing through my body at all times.
I can definitely,
you can feel when somebody,
when you know,
the finger of God is poking into your brain and kind of like mushing around and
being like,
well,
maybe,
you know what I mean?
It's like you can feel your body like not responding or responding,
I think,
you know what I mean?
Responding to the medication.
Why did they have you on it?
It's such a young age.
What was like a juvenile delinquent,
you know?
So I was like,
look like a fucking G.
I know the big swooping pompadour and shiny or I wouldn't trust you at all.
Yeah.
You know the classic,
I'm unhappy youth with the big glasses and 1950s movie.
Yeah.
No,
I mean I really,
I was,
I was a troubled kid.
Leather jacket.
Yeah,
no,
I was,
uh,
I was in the jets.
What did you do that what you were troubled,
so,
so much so that they wanted to put you on medication.
Well,
this is actually why what we were talking about before,
like I,
oh,
I went to rehab when was like 13
1213 years old.
I went to Reed,
I was in and out of Rehab that whole time and I've,
and I got sober and I was 15 and I was on my way here listening to your episode
of with Aubrey de Grey,
the grey different one.
No,
that's a,
I'll read Marcus the Iot
actually I've heard a great thing.
We've got to,
there's videos of it online for folks who have been asking me about that.
Yeah.
The,
the IOWASCA thing.
I walk us.
Yeah.
So I,
I,
it really made me think like every time I hear,
and I,
I've known about your sort of philosophical bent towards the world as a r e
psychedelics are sort of,
you know,
a freedom,
lifesaver kind of thing.
It can be.
Yeah.
And I was thinking as a person that's been clean and sober that long,
it's been a long time.
Right.
How long have,
you know,
I'm 34 yeah.
So 20 or 20 years.
Right.
So when I hear that kind of stuff,
I think to myself like,
this is unfair that I'm not,
that I have somehow put my little,
my life path has placed me in some sort of position where these sorts of things
because I,
you know,
I was taking mushrooms and acid when I was 12 years old.
Not,
not exactly the time when you're like looking for spiritual enlightenment.
Right.
You were just trying to get fucked.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh.
Or a hand job or something like that.
Uh,
and I had listened to that dude.
It's undeniable the truth of what he's,
what he's saying like that he was having this enlightenment moment.
It didn't sound like he went to Peru to party.
No,
he's had several of those.
Uh,
it's changed him as a,
as a human.
It's made him brighter,
like,
like the feeling that you get when you're around them.
I know that sounds ridiculous,
but it does happen to people.
Um,
everyone has this idea in their head that,
um,
if you are sober,
if you're a sober person,
you've gone,
you know,
x amount of years that you don't want to fall off the wagon and you don't want
to get back to where you were.
And it's totally,
completely understandable.
I,
uh,
I've talked to many friends that have that same sort of feeling like they're,
they're just like you.
They're like,
God,
I want to fucking try this.
Like our friend Tate Tate,
he similar thing,
a key,
he loved getting fucked up and he had an issue like,
oh,
I know the Tate Fletcher and he would do it and he would just go off the rails.
And so he's been sober for a long time,
long time.
He's very disciplined,
very healthy.
So when he sees something like Iowasca and all these benefits of,
it's like damn mother fucker.
Like,
you don't want to take that leap.
Like what if you like,
ah,
I'll just try it once and I'll be okay.
And then you're off on the fucking,
on the train through the woods.
No,
no rails.
Yeah.
Because there's this like membrane when you were a person that doesn't do drugs
or you're sober person.
Yeah.
There's this membrane between you and the rest of the world and it's paper thin,
but it keeps you on one side of the line.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Even though you can look on the other side of the line and Think,
oh well it would be fine to go to Peru or you know,
to go to,
you know,
some Iowasca ceremony and take,
if I could know that I would be doing that once I would go get enlightened
mentor,
whatever.
It's waiting for me there.
Come back across the line and be fine.
But once you rip that membrane into you and whether it's truth or programming,
you feel like,
I don't know if I could trust myself to not just stay on the other side for
everything.
That's interesting.
Have you ever,
um,
gone in for an operation or anything where they had to medicate you?
Yes.
Yeah.
What happens then?
I,
yeah,
I had my wisdom teeth out and I was put under and then I was taking,
um,
well one of the,
one of the saddest parts of being a person that doesn't,
that is a sober is that when you take a,
you know,
when they give you painkillers,
you take them as prescribed and if you take them as prescribed,
you really not going to get the fun part.
This is going to take away your pain.
You're like,
fuck man,
I thought this was a free look.
What kinds of they give you though?
I think I had um,
Vicodin.
I got news for you pal.
Yeah,
they got your hi.
Oh,
you mean the membrane has,
yeah,
if he took Vicodin.
I don't care if you took it as prescribed,
you got high.
It didn't,
I don't remember feeling,
I mean,
dude,
I would've loved it if that were true.
He just didn't get really high.
Yeah,
I didn't,
I didn't write down anything like Vicodin.
Let's try it.
You'll have some ready.
Hold on.
What does that tell you about leaving that shit here?
I told you take it with you,
put it in your fucking pocket.
I do not want that shit here because if I tell the cops no,
there's no viking in here and then they find Vicodin.
I don't have a prescription for that shit around.
You do not have a prescription for anything.
It was the last time you went to a fucking doctor.
Why didn't line up?
I go to the dentist.
They'll have record of it.
Wait,
how many different drugs do you have that I just referenced one.
And you pulled out a bag within one second.
Oh you mean this stuff?
It says four PS.
Four or five minutes.
Cause I just lucky doesn't have an office here.
If he had an office here,
I'd have to fucking send dogs in there and once a month to see what's in there.
I didn't like it.
That's why I still have it.
They gave me a bottle of,
I took two of them.
I was like fuck this shit.
See what I'm talking about?
The membrane.
I didn't like it.
That's why I still have it.
That's the problem.
You find yourself saying things like,
I didn't like it.
That's why I kept it.
I wanted to make sure I had a close.
I think that's what they gave me when I had my first knee operation.
I took it and I hated it.
Yeah.
It just made me feel so stupid.
It was either vicodins or what's the other one that,
uh,
that people take that they actually say make some creative.
There's another painkiller,
like FICA and very calm and painkiller.
Oxy.
No,
no,
no.
What?
Percocet.
That,
yeah,
it's either a,
it was either Viking into Percodan Percocet.
It was one of them,
but it was bad,
whatever it was.
But I gave it to this guy at the pool hall.
I sold it to him.
He was super happy.
Can we just like,
yeah,
you got these.
Like,
it's like,
like some people just want to get dumb,
you know,
there was this blonde guys name was Jeff.
Hey,
there's always had long greasy hair and he would wear a Jean jacket with cutoff
sleeves guide.
Yeah.
And you know,
he's always hanging around the pool hall.
He was like a classic Dickinson's character,
you know,
if it was like,
1992,
which is when he was around,
but he was just classic,
like looked like he was a Leonard Skinner and fan back in their price.
Joe,
you got some perks,
gross greasy mustache.
He's just crazy.
And he bought
the perks.
He fuck,
Yay Joe.
Right on man.
Fuck the pom.
Got them perks.
So you,
even if you did do it,
whatever you did
do didn't get you fucked up enough.
Where you worried about falling back into who you were when you were 12.
Well,
the thing is,
what's interesting is about being in a sober person,
being in 12 step groups is that like,
and as a person who's now 34,
I haven't been to a 12 step meeting on a long time,
but I still have a lot of that.
Uh,
uh,
it's sorta still the,
the,
the foundation of building blocks of a lot of my sort of moral code and
personality.
Uh,
is that you,
you recognize?
I recognize looking back,
like a lot of what I think about drugs is programming,
programming that I've,
you know,
that I've tried on,
on purpose.
You know what I mean?
I've accepted willingly this kind of programming,
but on the other hand,
it's,
there's also realistic,
you know,
there's reality about it.
Like,
do you,
do you be Aubrey or do you be Jeff from the pool hall?
Like,
it's very difficult to know what's going to happen.
You don't know.
You know,
you might,
you might be,
you know,
in the river of time and you might be,
uh,
at the dead show,
you know,
parking lot,
trying to fuck a 16 year old Hula Hooper.
Um,
you know,
I think we also have a lot of misconceptions about how drugs affect us and what
would the addiction process is.
And I know I probably still do,
but I had this guy on the podcast name is Dr. Carl Hart and he's a fascinating
character because you know,
he's had both real life experiences with drugs and you know,
he's,
he's a professor of psycho psychology and Psychiatry at Columbia.
He's a super brilliant guy who wrote this book and um,
uh,
his book is called high price and it's interesting,
the book is,
a lot of it is about the actual effects of drugs,
his own life and his own personal personal situation.
Um,
the,
the things that he's experienced personally but fascinating,
fascinating.
When it comes to the aspect of like what are the actual mechanisms of addiction
and what are the misconceptions and the misconceptions about the mechanisms of
addiction are that,
you know,
someone smokes crack and then all of a sudden they're addicted and he's like,
that's not how it works.
And,
and being addicted itself and like coming off of it,
it's like everyone makes it seem like cause it's horrible life or death thing
and he's like,
have you had the flu?
Well then you know what it's like to withdrawal.
That's all it is,
but there's,
there's like shit.
It's interesting though.
There's two different,
there's two aspects of it.
There's the flu and then there was some kind of weird personality flaw that
makes you really,
really unable to deal with having the flu.
You know what I mean?
Like cause I,
I've helped people get off heroin and stuff and it's like,
yeah,
this sucks,
but you're on heroin,
right?
Like it seems so obvious.
Get through this horrible part.
You won't be on heroin anymore.
Then I think that Flint and then they shoot fucking dope again and it's like
what?
Logically if you're putting these things on this,
on a balance sheet,
logically you're right.
It's just a fucking flute.
What we know,
and it's terrible for you,
but there's this other weird part where it is like you have the flu and there's
a little voice going.
Like if you just press this button,
the flu will be gone immediately.
The flutes going to become,
I mean instantly,
instantly.
So this like this little voice chipping away at your head.
That's the issue.
It's the voice more than it is the physical actual withdrawal symptoms.
Yeah,
no doubt.
And also there's this thing that they talk about in 12 step groups,
which is the strange mental blank spots.
You know.
So like when you look at the,
you know,
you have a series of consequences,
that's built up as a result of being a drug addict or an alcoholic.
And then you,
you know,
all of those things leading up to the,
the bottle,
you know,
oh my wife left me,
I lost my job,
I've got hepatitis,
you know,
and then the moment you look at a bag of heroin,
you forget all of those for you have a,
uh,
an instant of consciousness,
you know,
disappearing and you just forget all the consequences.
All you can think about is the relief that's in that little Baggie.
Do you think that a lot of what the 12 step program provides is like a structure
and sort of like a discipline?
And when you follow that structure and you follow a discipline,
a lot of times you're like less likely to go off the rails because you have sort
of an ethical,
you have like the standards ships supposed to apply,
like accountability,
you know,
like one of the things that I found really interesting about 12 step is that
people that I've known that got sober,
one of the things it would have to do is go and find people that they had issues
with and,
and apologize.
I was really just kind of fascinating.
You know,
you talked to someone like,
you know,
so why'd you,
what made you compelled to go reach out to this person?
And you know,
their,
their idea behind it was that there's some psychic weight to all this stuff that
sort of weighs you down and makes you feel like you're not a good person.
And when you feel like you're not a good person,
it makes it easier for you to do something that's not good for you.
I think that's right.
I think that the missing piece there,
I think that's 100% right.
And then the missing piece there is that it's not even that it makes doing
something that isn't good for you.
It's,
it's something that can make you instantly forget about yourself.
And that's the sort of weird cycle.
It's the moment that you get high or drink,
then you stop thinking about all of the psychic weight that you've been carrying
around with you.
So you feel a little bit lighter and freer.
Unfortunately by being a drug addict and continuing to drink,
you're creating more and more psychic weight,
your career,
you're creating more and more damage in the wake of your life.
So you have to keep,
it's just horrible.
You know,
he donek treadmill of like,
you know,
trauma and relief.
So I,
yeah,
but I think the other thing that 12 step groups do,
and like I said,
I,
it's been a long time for me that they,
they,
they impose whether it's real or not,
they impose a value,
a life or death value to being sober.
Where it's like we're engaged in this cosmic struggle.
You know,
you come to these meetings to find your other brethren that are also addicted.
And then you'd go out and you help those brethren and then we're here in this,
it's the most,
it's the primary.
Anybody who's active in,
in 12 step groups will say,
uh,
you know,
the primary fact of my life is that I'm a sober guy.
And if you,
and that's it,
self perpetuated.
I don't think it's in a bad,
I don't think that's a bad thing.
But when you leave a AA meetings,
when you leave 12th step and you stopped going,
that value that,
that sort of a cosmic buildup of what that means goes away.
And then the reason that you're sober becomes,
it's just a good idea,
which is a much less compelling reason to stay sober than I'm engaged in a
cosmic struggle to find my brother and,
and,
and save their lives.
But on the flip side,
it makes you less annoying about it when you leave,
when you,
the way you're describing it.
Yes.
By leaving it,
I'm less than,
it's a good idea as opposed to this life or death struggle because so many
people that are sober,
they're like crossfitters.
It's all you ever fucking here.
Out of him,
you know,
you told him doing crossfit,
like I guess people that just start doing Jujitsu are guilty of it as well.
Everything,
every single thing,
everything.
The newly converted person is the most annoying human being that exists across
the board,
across the board,
everything.
Guilty as charged.
Every,
all of us are.
I think that you,
you know,
you get excited about something,
it becomes a part of who you are and then you see the positive results of now
you're sober.
Now you don't have to wake up in the gutter covered in your own fucking throw up
and just,
you know,
shit in your pants.
And the problem with Jujitsu is you can't come to me and tell me,
Oh,
I'm brother Jujitsu.
Save every year.
I'd be like,
oh,
that's a martial art.
I don't have one.
It's like religion.
It can become like,
no,
no.
This is the answer.
All humans must learn the Anaconda choke or whatever.
This,
this is the truth.
And it,
and that's the other thing also is like if someone had success for them,
they think this is the only way.
And that your way,
oh,
you're fucking,
you're going down a bad road,
Marsha.
And what are you doing there with yoga?
You know,
Yoga is designed by devils.
It was originally by,
by demons.
Demons gave it to people so they can convert them.
Well,
that's actually what's interesting.
Speaking of the SSRI thing is I remember when I was in,
uh,
when I was actively going to meetings,
there was this sort of weird offshoot within Aa and it wasn't,
no,
there's no official sanctioning really,
and in Aa,
but there,
there's sort of currents of thought and one of them would be to sort of
passively dissuade people from using second psychiatric drugs in the name of
sobriety.
So you'd have these people coming in that were clearly very disturbed people and
up some plumber going,
oh,
we don't do that here.
We don't,
we don't take those drugs here.
Was it?
It was like,
oh,
are you a psychiatrist?
Toughen up.
Yeah.
No,
I'm a plumber and I know what I'm talking about.
Norm.
You stop listening to them.
I got a voice that me all kinds of shit.
Let me just stop you right now.
I'm not going to do it.
That it's,
yeah,
no,
it's more like I don't have a voice so you don't need a voice.
Okay,
let's move on.
Yeah.
People who are,
who like sobriety,
you know,
and,
and our end of that world,
they have a real hard time believing that you could go out and have a drink.
Like there was a,
a,
a guy who
used to own the Tempe Improv and he was sober guy and like super,
super sober to the point where they lied and made up a rule about the stage.
And they said Comedians can't drink on stage because it's a state law.
Not True.
Not True at all.
That's not right.
Yeah.
And so,
you know,
there's like a sign there that they have in the,
in the green room talking about how as a state law and then we found out that it
was bullshit.
So we found that it was bullshit and we started,
we brought a flask on stage once the store and it was Brian's idea to go to a
liquor store and get a flat.
So I had a flask on stage and I was explaining to the audience that I was just
pouring warm diet coke and in my cold diet coke,
because I sort of a medium diet coke or it's you've got a regular heat
temperature to warm diet coke and a flask that's next to my butt heats it up.
But this guy was,
he would,
you would go to take a drink before you go on stage.
Like,
uh,
can I get a shot?
You know,
you go to the bar and you're paying for it too.
I pay for it and I'm not asking you for free.
I always pay for it.
I give the bartender money,
I want,
you know,
I'm not,
I'm not trying to get,
so the point is I get this shot and you know,
the,
the owners like shaking his head like upset that the bartender gave it to me.
We have to have this conversation.
Like,
I'll do it.
It's a shot.
It's one shot.
I'm going to go on stage.
I know what I'm doing.
Like,
trust me,
I'm not,
I'm not a drunk.
I'm not out of control.
I'm a professional comedian,
I'm going to have a drink and then I'm going to go do all this material that had
been working on for a long fucking time.
Like this isn't like some reckless endeavor.
I'm going to fucking throw caution to the wind.
Throw one back,
Bang,
a fucking shot of heroin or morphine depository,
my asshole.
You go pository going from red band over there and these guys calling ready?
Well,
they have those morphine suppository.
He's supposed to be incredible.
You know you're the only the comedian that drinks alcohol.
I am.
You're the only one.
So that's why he was so shocked.
Sense.
I'm sorry,
near the AOL of drinking comedians.
It's just so fucking stupid that a guy would say you got a room full of people
that are drinking.
You're selling them booze and you don't want me to have a shot before I go on
stage.
Evangelism of any,
any kind of evangelism is the,
is the enemy.
Unless you really
do know something.
Could you imagine if you really did find the fountain of Youth?
If you very frustrated,
you're are old and fucked up being jumped in,
boom.
He came out,
you're 20 years old and you're running to all these people and they're like,
get the fuck away from me.
You crazy ass.
Well,
you're not 60 you're fucking 20
I've found the truth.
That's how they all feel like.
Just be so aware of sobers.
Awesome.
It's interesting,
isn't it?
If you've ever been to Jerusalem and Jerusalem,
there's this thing where people move there to go blues their mind.
Oh,
Jerusalem Syndrome go there.
I don't know if they go get on an airplane thinking they're the Messiah or if
they go there with those latent seeds of like with a moment I walk into
Jerusalem,
I'm going to lose my mind,
but you will walk around the Old City of Jerusalem and they will be nine or 10
Messiah's there who are American and I was,
what a crazy coincidence that you well that is great.
I love that.
I fucking love that.
That's pretty hot.
It's pretty amazing.
That exists.
There was a vice special about it recently.
Oh really?
The HBO show,
they followed all these people that went to Jerusalem,
whacked out Americans with southern accents.
You just going into tongues and reading from scripture and,
oh,
that was about the American evangelical evangelical supporting the State of
Israel.
I did see that.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's and who go over there and just go bananas.
Not as far.
I mean,
they weren't,
I don't think there was any messiah's on that show,
but yeah,
no,
I saw their level,
all of the same nonsense.
That's a much more subtle version of Jerusalem.
That's right.
I think there was a cover of,
I think that was a title of one of Mark Marin's book.
It was,
yeah.
Yeah.
He had like a one man show he was doing about that.
Probably based on themselves a little bit like,
right.
I have the book at home actually.
Mark,
if you're listening we say hello.
Hello?
Yeah,
I think it was a,
I think it was supposed to be really funny book.
I never got around to reading it,
but I heard good things.
I mean,
he's good.
The guy's good.
That's what I'm saying.
So when you got out,
how long did you stay in treatment before you decided to be this guy who's just
sober?
Because it's a good idea.
Oh,
you mean how long have I been in my current iteration of what it means to be a
person that doesn't do drugs
without,
yeah.
Without the 12 step ideology attached to it.
Like how long have you been free of going to meetings and all that stuff?
Oh,
free.
All,
all your silver listeners.
It's a Tupac lyric.
You know,
I first,
when I first went clear,
um,
no,
I stopped funding meeting.
I don't know.
I had a weird experience because I got sober so incredibly young.
I was,
I was 15.
You haven't talked to in Norton about that?
Uh,
no,
no.
Get sober.
Really Young.
No similar.
Yeah,
I think he was like 18 or 19.
Right.
So the whole group of people I was with was like the were 15,
16,
17,
18 in fact,
that was like the youngest guy that got sober in where in Oakland,
where I'm from.
But there was this whole circle of kids that got sober at the same time.
We all kind of hung out and you know,
made this kind of social reality with each other.
And then one by one of course,
they all got older and started to think very reasonably well,
that was probably a phase,
right?
What am I doing here?
This is 10 years later,
I'm 28 years old.
I've been sober 10 years,
like how the hell do I even,
you know,
I didn't know how to date people.
I didn't know how to fuck people.
I did.
If you had to go back to you,
if you had to be weekly meetings in order to caress the personality that you
were developing when you were in high school,
like who you define yourself as and it was based on who you were in high school.
That's exactly right.
There are so undeveloped.
Nothing about me is true.
That was true.
Then today,
and then there's this kernel that you hold on to,
which is this idea that you're a person that needs to be sober,
that that's where things get a little bit hazy and Wonky,
so one by one.
All of those people that I got sober with started to started drinking again.
We started getting high again and then you go,
well now I'm 34 years old.
I've been sober 20 years.
I don't know.
I couldn't honestly tell you it was or wasn't a phase.
But I also couldn't honestly tell you if I started getting high again that I
wouldn't fucking just pull the,
the slowly pull the plug on the stability of what I've got.
Hey,
I see.
This is where I think that for a lot of folks,
especially like you who's a pretty rational guy,
obviously you know we're having a normal conversation.
You know what I'm saying?
Anything Nutty,
I'm pretty sure you're on the ball.
You're successful comedian,
you're well regarded.
He got a lot of good things going on.
I don't see you with destructive behavior anywhere else.
So it becomes in what is making it so destructive?
I mean is it because it just some genetic component of your body that when takes
in some sort of a mind altering substance,
it just goes nutty?
I mean,
I have,
I don't know the answer to that because like north it,
Martin is a good example.
I love that guy.
He's awesome.
But Norton is clearly crazy and good ways,
and it's one of the reasons why he's so hilarious,
but he's a complete total sex addict.
Right.
Super Open about it.
So we all are,
well,
he's in a different league.
No,
no,
I'm not saying I'm on Norton level.
He takes it to another leg.
He's like,
yeah,
he's like the Michael Jordan of,
of functional perverts.
So he,
um,
he's obviously got that personality.
He's got that maniac that,
I mean it's,
it's so common and Comedians,
it's almost like if you see your kid and he's kind of crazy and super impulsive
and doing dangerous shit,
start steering them towards stand up,
you know?
Right,
right.
You know,
I mean,
this is the one thing where you can actually have a healthy human being can
develop out of this very bizarre personality trait.
Because,
I mean,
even myself,
if I,
if I had gotten stuck and some sort of a job that I didn't agree to,
I didn't enjoy,
but I needed the money and then I got a mortgage or a family and then I'm
trapped and I'm stuck in there.
I would for sure be some sort of off the rails junkie for sure.
I just,
I'm impulsive,
I'm very impulsive and uh,
and,
and I,
I'm capable of making terrible decisions,
but I keep it all in check and I keep it all in check through working out and I
keep it all in check through having the kind of paths like for like for hobbies
and for,
for things that I enjoy doing,
like standup career stuff where they're wild,
crazy things where it's okay to be nutty,
you know,
and being nutty.
There's actually a benefit.
You could be kind of more creative and you come up with these things that a lot
of people would never say,
but they find hilarious.
Like you find a path for,
I like Joey Diaz,
another perfect example.
Always had mad struggles with drugs his whole life.
He's completely impulsive,
you know,
he's,
he's like,
I'm on a diet,
I'm on this new thing.
What's that sec?
Give me that fucking sandwich and just fucking take your meatball sub and just
slam it down.
Like,
what happened?
He died.
Fuck that diet and fucking mother,
you know,
he'll just,
he just gone,
it'll go off the rails,
you know,
but you're not,
you don't seem to be off the rails kind of guy.
Well,
I mean,
I think that I present,
I don't think I,
I'm not disagreeing or agreeing with you.
I don't,
I,
I present,
I think better than I present.
Well,
right.
I,
I have my neurosis,
my clear neurosis.
I've,
you know,
and I've certainly struggled with sex stuff a lot.
Okay.
Do,
do,
is that the struggle with sex stuff?
That's the,
uh,
either you're getting high or the struggle was what everybody has.
No,
of course.
I mean,
it's a whole mind fuck.
And the other thing is that,
what is the drug that they say rearranges the addictive process and your brain
anyway,
it's a psychedelic as well.
The Boga that ebook.
So it's like,
who even knows?
Maybe you have the membrane gets ripped wide open and you come through the,
you know,
the other side of completely different person with a different process.
What would I begin?
Does.
I haven't done it.
But what I began does,
uh,
according to the people that have is,
it sort of shows you every aspect of your personality and what's causing all
these different behavior patterns,
whether it's self destructive behavior,
whether it's self loathing behavior,
whether it's a anxiety in security.
The root of it all is kind of explained to you in a very unusual and unique way.
So it's not like dimethyltryptamine is the active ingredient and Iowasca and the
people that go on the high of Wasc or retreats,
what they experienced is the very chemical that is responsible for divine
feelings,
for,
for dreams,
for probably for near death experiences.
It's your,
it's released in the mind.
It's released in the brain,
in its released through this gland that's literally your third eye.
It sits in the middle of your brain and eastern mysticism.
All those pictures of the enlightened ones,
the glowing third eye,
that's the pineal gland.
You know,
they know for a fact that DMT is being produced there in live mice.
So it's most likely DMT is being proved there and human beings.
And the theory is that when you take any of these drugs,
like when it's what it's like a swastika or whether it's a,
what it does is allow you to stop being you for a while and see the whole wiring
under the board,
see all the,
the microcosm,
the fractal nature of the universe itself and see it in a way that's absolutely
impossible.
I began doesn't do that.
I'm again shows you you,
it shows you you in like this really harsh and unusual way where it just shows
you like almost a mathematical components of all the various things that have
gone wrong in your life and why they're leading up to this.
And then on top of that,
it rewires your whole addictive mechanism in your mind.
It's very trippy stuff because there was the success rate rather for people
who've done it with addictions is astronomical.
I mean it's huge.
It's like way more than 50% right?
Way more than 50% of the people that go there and do it.
Never do drugs again.
Heroine addicts,
pill heads,
all these people.
I had a friend who did it and he was so powerful that he opened up a retreat
down there.
My friend Ed clay,
it's got a retreat and do retreat in Mexico.
Yeah,
that's the complicated thing about like just to poke back on the,
on the Io Osca idea.
How do you know that what you're experiencing is true enlightenment?
I mean these are hallucinations.
Sure.
So like in,
on what level can you trust the hallucination?
Like
it's a very good question.
Here's my take on it.
You know,
it's,
it's something that people always worry about.
Like say if you do a drug,
that drug takes you to the divine consciousness at the center of everything.
And this divine consciousness explains to you that the insecurities of your
being and all this madness that you're experiencing in your life is really just
your biological mechanisms.
This,
the remnants of the monkey body that have had to run from predators your entire
life.
And all this savagery is still entwined in the very DNA that causes your cells
to duplicate.
Like it's,
it's almost unavoidable.
And then you have to find peace through love.
And you have to find the center of this and you come out of that experience like
blown away.
You just had a conversation with God.
You just,
you've learned about yourself,
you're a happier,
more relaxed person,
your anxiety's gone.
You see the finish line,
you see something over the cross,
the boundary between life and death.
Whether or not that actually happened or whether it was a complete total
hallucination.
It's the same experience,
right?
The experience is exactly the same and it's,
it's,
it's a foolish thing to wonder about if it's beneficial.
If you really do have that experience.
Was it a who says what did the fuck is a hallucination?
That's,
how about that?
How about what is seeing something that's not there?
What are you saying?
It's not there.
You're seeing it like it's not there because you can't put it in a bag and take
it home
and other chemicals sitting in your brain anyway.
Then it is their whatever chemical makes you see things.
Exactly.
And light is just as much a hallucination created by your brain.
There's anything else is right.
It's a different state of consciousness.
But like the,
you know,
the,
uh,
the classic image of the person on acid,
like writing down his thoughts.
He's like,
oh,
I had this crazy enlightenment last night.
You have to come see,
and the opens up his diary and it's just like,
be cool bro.
No.
Could it be that simple?
Well,
there's also the issue of the words that we use to describe reality itself were
created in this state of consciousness and the state of consciousness that you
experience when you're in any sort of an intense psychedelic state is so bizarre
and alien that the word that we use to reference things and in this state,
they're not effective enough.
They're just,
they're not you,
you can't dis McKenna used to describe a Terrence from Kenny's described DMT
experiences as self transforming machine elves.
You know,
and the first time I did it,
I remember thinking,
how the fuck did he get self transforming machine elves out of this?
Because it didn't seem like that to me at all.
But it's because the,
it's silly.
The words don't work.
It's like what it is is so fucking alien that you can't describe it.
The closest thing you can do
is look at an Alex great painting.
You know,
the Alex Grey has all this amazing intense psychedelic art.
Like Brian pull up one of those Alex Gray paintings.
He has these intense,
intense tryptamine inspired,
uh,
artistic renderings,
paintings and such.
Those are probably the closest thing you'll ever get.
And even those,
yeah,
he did this big old,
the installation at burning man a couple of years ago.
It was just this huge dome that was all Alex Gray paintings and him presenting
like every night.
Yeah.
Like this.
Yeah,
exactly.
That is a perfect example of a trip to mean based experience that's put in some
sort of a painting and it's unbelievably beautiful and fantastic and all that.
But it still falls way short of the actual experience was,
do you know,
it's interesting,
I'm looking at this as a person that's been sober for 20 years but has done
psychedelics and how even though I was so young,
they were so,
they were definitely a,
a fundamental part of my development.
I still relate to this kind of imagery.
You will.
That is probably because it's part of your dreams.
You're experiencing that at night.
They don't know what we're experiencing during dreams.
Just a lot of,
a lot of guesswork about that.
But they're,
they're trying to do more detailed studies on the effects of dimethyltryptamine
in dreams.
I'm mostly having sex with my mom.
Oh Shit.
You,
it must be hot.
She's very hot.
And that was where you were.
You were looking for the diabolical part of my personality.
I'm just incredibly attracted to my mom.
He just a motherfucker.
I'm just this spray motherfucker.
Well,
as long as your mom's into it too.
I really don't see what anything's wrong with that.
Well,
let's find out.
She's a listener.
She's not a listener.
She's deaf
comedy mode.
Can you tell she's really deaf.
Oh No,
no,
I'm not.
Instead of company mode,
my mom's death,
she really is,
can say anything you want to about your mom.
I can't,
you can have as long as your eventual,
cause she could talk our icons of mad shit.
Yeah.
Or just put your hand over your mouth.
We used to do that.
Well,
my mom would say something we would just like on the brush our mouth and just be
like,
fuck you bitch.
Yeah.
She probably could sense the vibrations coming off silverware and stuff so she
could sense the psychic vibrations.
It'd be like,
fuck you bitch.
She would sign it though.
But real hood,
you know,
monkeys,
monkeys will fuck each other like crazy.
Like especially like,
um,
but no nobos Banabos we'll fuck everything.
But the mother will never fuck the sun.
Right.
That's the only taboo.
Yeah.
So the father will fuck the daughter.
The mother won't fuck the sun and that is the primary pain of my life.
But I've been running from this whole time.
That's why I went to Rehab.
That's why I want to do Ibogaine.
Make sense?
Do I want to meet my mother?
The
psychedelic landscape?
Well,
one thing about Ibogaine is it's supposed to be like,
really it's so gross that no one ever wants to do it again other than to try to
heal themselves.
Right.
Never the hard way about being recreational.
They say that about DMT as well.
That's true.
And I,
and I think that when I think about a iosco
or DMT or I guess at the same sort of,
or,
or I began,
I don't know,
I that just seems to medicinal from you.
It's not that I think,
oh,
I'm going to go start partying on Iowasca every weekend.
It's that,
like I said that when,
once that,
I think the Iowasca trip would be positive no matter what.
But once you take away that line between you and a person that doesn't get high,
then it's gone.
Yeah.
I guess you'd have to figure that out yourself.
Thing anybody could ever tell you.
Yeah.
I mean,
what can they do?
I was just hoping you could,
well,
I've never had a drug problem,
so I don't,
you know,
a lot of people will tell me I'm wrong and I'm lying.
You wrote drugs road,
no Hippie,
you go to fucking drug problem.
Uh,
I just like substances them never been an issue with me.
Never been in shoot.
Like I had to do it.
Like I've not smoked weed for weeks at a time.
It hasn't bothered me drinking.
It doesn't bother me at all.
I never,
never crave week drinking.
But according to Carl Hart,
all our ideas about like addictions and cravings and stuff like that,
it's,
it's way more psychological than it is physical.
And that when you feel hung over,
like that feeling that you have when you drink and then you're fucked up and
then [inaudible] morning you're in pain,
he goes,
you are experiencing alcohol withdrawals.
Like you're experiencing them right there.
That is what being hung over his.
So this idea that you're addicted to alcohol because you have this honey
hangover,
these withdrawals,
and then you know you can't kick it.
And then in the future you're addicted again.
Like you're addicted right away.
It's just these compensatory mechanisms.
So there was,
there's a responsible for all that horrible feeling,
the headache and all that stuff.
It's the compensatory mechanisms where they're trying to compensate for the fact
that you've poured this poisons alcohol in your body,
so your body is like raging against it.
And it sort of adjusting all the levels and then there's no more alcohol and
it's like,
that's half of why you feel like shit.
Oh,
that's fascinating,
isn't it?
So everybody that's hung over as an alcoholic for an hour and a half.
Well,
alcoholic is a weird word.
You know,
being addicted to alcohol,
you know what it,
whatever it is,
whatever addiction is,
you know,
and so it's the whole state is very strange.
The idea that you have a substance that becomes so much of a part of your
everyday life that even though it's bad for you,
you need to put it in your body.
Well,
it's fascinating.
You go down to downtown la anytime and just drive around.
Anytime you're feeling sorry for yourself about your career or the way things
are going to go down there and you go,
oh,
weird.
You go look at a crack addict and you go,
this person decided to do crack instead of all of the other things.
Forget no work,
no family,
no interest,
no hobbies,
no books,
no,
no school,
no.
Just I do.
I'm a person that does crack.
My human experience has been to get money to smoke crack.
That's it.
That's what I've checked out.
What if you never been to skid row and you're in La,
you've got to try it.
It's the vacation destination of the year.
This week's episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by skid
just to see where we're at because everybody like has this idea that one day
we're going to have some sort of a walking dead type apocalyptic scenario.
It's already here we're,
we're ready.
It's just a small spot.
It's only like a block or two or a couple of blocks,
but full long la downtown blocks are filled with villages of homeless people
wandering around like zombies shooting up,
yelling at each other.
This is not the Congo Kinshasa.
This is not Flint,
Michigan.
This is one of the biggest cities in America,
the most rich,
vibrant cities in America in downtown.
There are is a straight up Zombie Apocalypse village waiting for you to visit
and people would think we're lying or see if you can find a video of skid row
just so people can find it.
You need a bathroom break?
Yeah,
get in there son.
Where is their right to that door?
Go through that door and uh,
while you're at it,
there was one of those battle rap videos that somebody put on the underground,
uh,
on a message board rather.
Um,
with these two guys are battle rapping in the middle of it.
One guy shoots heroin
shoot heroin in the middle of a battle rap.
Yeah.
His name's Cadillac Ron.
So pull up Cadillac.
Ron shoots up in the middle of a battle rap and Ted,
10 minutes in there in the middle of which,
you know,
most battle rap,
I think it's dog shit.
So it just like,
you know,
all this craziness about how I do you peel your cap back.
You know,
I do the,
you know,
I'm,
I'm the baddest motherfucker,
blah,
blah.
Most of it's silly.
I've had a lot of battle rapper say,
and let me come on and explain it.
Fuck you bitch.
I can see your shit online.
I see what you're doing.
I think,
I just think there's some people are good at it.
Oh yeah,
it's real.
Yeah.
He really shoots up.
If you're going to show,
what are you doing?
I'm showing a whole word.
Oh,
get it to 10 minutes in.
He,
um,
you know,
he shoots it.
What's interesting is he shoots up and then immediately becomes way better.
So if I was his manager,
I would say continue shooting up because uh,
this is where your expertise lies.
This guy was,
I guess he was like,
who is fucked up on drugs?
And then he got sober.
Now he's fucked up on drugs again.
It's interesting when something like this happens and someone does something
crazy,
then all these people who are like fans of is,
they kind of fill you in on the background.
There's so many rappers out there that it's impossible to keep an eye on all of
them.
You know,
people were always bringing up new names.
It's not like rappers retire like every year there's like a million new ones.
It's impossible to keep track of all of them.
But this guy has a lot of fans,
talented rapper in the middle of this,
10 minutes into this battle rap,
he steps back and uh,
I saw that he shoots up.
Yeah,
this is,
so this is
right now he's totally shooting up right now.
Look at this
and now he starts popping around.
Wow.
How Tommy these kids are.
They're like,
you can clap.
Their guide is buried juice.
Where's the owner at?
And this is him talking now.
Okay.
We're not doing heroin and walking into cheers woody.
Get Norman.
Oh,
just go to the post man.
Shit.
Everybody knows me.
Oh,
the blown.
Even me,
if I had it my way all to live in my bed,
but constant morphine,
Oxycontin,
Kogi,
methadone dog to sit here and cocaine freebase China white mixed with Mtma
immediately administer me being asleep to the main things on my penis
out of his [inaudible].
This is all going my admin.
If I see any prescription drugs,
I'm fucking granted him.
Second Medicine Cabinets,
he has Cadillac wrong based on Brynne's with the ED.
It's even not a Cadillac.
It's fucking suck at tab is plenty.
It's not concentrated enough.
Ball play motherfucker.
You been in the county.
What?
The boy days while my best friend you were five years for aggravated assault.
It wasn't as though shit.
Everybody I know don't put basically a medical leave of absence,
thanksgiving night,
tweak an accident.
My absence shall be smoked at $40 a crack by myself.
Scanning,
share it and how are you with messenger?
Funny slice.
The air was saying fuck you.
Do your parents ruined your life.
Watch maybe do the down stroke on purpose.
Why be sober when you could be high.
See I listened to sun spot.
I'm going to drop to the jungles in back on multiple gunshot.
Oo,
bucks.
Stop pumps up.
Sold 12 games.
Pullbacks triggers are so busy that I have.
I'm fucking days.
Okay.
I mean that was bad heroin because that,
you know,
didn't seem to work cause he can still talk.
Right?
Well he's an addict.
Yeah.
He just got the flu to go away.
That little monkey was like,
good,
good work.
Let's get back to hip hop.
That's the thing that happens to people that become addicts is that this need is
like this horrible thing and then you get,
you feel the need and that makes you even [inaudible].
That's what they call it.
Chasing the dragon.
The dragon is the first heroine experience.
Did you do heroin?
I never did heroin.
What was your specialty?
And Man,
I was a kid.
So kid,
kid stuff,
Lsd,
mushrooms,
weed,
alcohol.
So what made you decide like,
oh my God,
I'm fucked up.
I gotta get sober.
Well,
I was,
I was in and out of Rehab,
you know,
crazy Rehab for alcohol like we have for what?
I honestly as a,
as an adult now looking back,
I think it was,
I was sent there for behavioral issues.
I was a juvenile delinquent and that was the primary thing.
I mean,
I don't know that I really believe in drug addiction in the way that I used,
you know,
the,
uh,
I think that the paradigm of what addiction is within 12 step and within Rehab
is that addiction is,
this is a permanent spiritual state of being,
you know?
Right.
But you are,
you,
that's what you are and that's what you always will be.
That's the main criticism of things like alcoholics anonymous,
that and God,
yeah,
the God part part is a little weird from my perspective.
And I'm not a,
I'm not an ardent atheist by any means,
but it is a little weird for like you Joe,
you hit rock bottom,
you're just some guy and then you my solution to you as okay,
we'll come
meet God.
It's like,
well that doesn't seem like don't they allow you to substitute that for a higher
power?
Yeah.
Sort of like the idea that like maybe you could substitute it for the universe.
Sure.
But it's all just mental apologetics.
I mean it's still a spiritual what,
why am I going to court and I'm a federal judges mandating me to go,
you know,
to have the spirit of the universe heal me.
It doesn't,
it doesn't make sense.
I'm into it.
What with the federal judge when you mean,
well like you could go to court for a drug related charge and have a judge say
you must go to Aa meetings for the 90 days.
Right?
And then you get to Aa meetings and the thing they say to you is you find a
power greater than yourself to restore you to sanity.
There's a disconnect there.
Why is there a government official telling you to go to a,
uh,
a sense of what's essentially a church?
What do you think that maybe that could be just because there's a lack of other
viable
options for a judge?
Like if you want to get someone sober,
narcotics anonymous,
alcoholics anonymous.
It's pretty much the only thing that we've shown that,
you know,
has good,
a high rate of efficacy.
I think that it's what people,
I think that it's the paradigm that we're living in,
that people go there.
I'm for it.
I like it.
It helps me or helped me when I was young.
I,
I'm,
I'm all for it,
but I do think that there's an argument to be made.
It's like,
why is some atheist drug addict being sent to a God based organization?
It just does seem a little bit weird.
Hmm.
Well,
I think the standard that we have today as far as what we believe works and what
we've shown the work,
the people that we know that have stayed sober,
they've gone that route.
The ibogaine route is so alien to Western culture that we haven't used it as an
option,
but if it was an option and we had,
and I guarantee you it would make,
it would make being in 12 step programs be like sending smoke signals as opposed
to calling somebody.
Well that's interesting.
Well,
what we should do,
Joe,
is we should get a big bucket of Ibogaine and go to all the Aa meetings in town
and put it in the coffee and just dose
you got to him if he wants some.
I'm sure you do.
There's a,
there's a bunch of articles online for anybody who's interested in a,
I have a gain,
but anybody who has any sort of an addiction,
I would recommend it wholeheartedly.
I haven't done it myself,
but I everyone that I know that's done it,
that has had some sort of an addiction is kicked it.
That's amazing.
Not just kicked it,
but man,
my friend Ed is the best example.
He's,
he's so different now.
He's just so any super s very,
he was always very motivated.
He was always very successful.
Real estate investments,
always doing a bunch of different things.
He's still successful,
but it's a way different way.
Now he's just more,
he's more present,
more relaxed,
like he's a kinder person that he gives off this different sort of relaxed
feeling.
It's very,
very interesting and unique.
And you know,
he's completely free of any of the pills that were,
were playing him.
And for him,
he was a pretty healthy guy,
just get injured.
And once he got injured,
he was taking pain pills and then whoop off to the,
yeah,
that
is a weird thing.
And I said,
there's a little monkey inside of everybody.
It's not just some kind of spiritually broken person,
but if I,
you know,
if you take enough pills,
yeah,
you're,
you're gonna get,
you're gonna get addicted.
Well,
Carl Hart was talking about the,
um,
the prevalence of these prescribed drugs in prescribing these oxycontin and all
these different things,
and they're like,
it's a really incredibly potent drugs.
Right?
They're being prescribed like crazy because they can make a lot of money off of
them.
You know,
they just came up with some new drug that's far more potent than Oxycontin,
and I remember reading that going,
who's complaining is this Oxycontin's bull shit.
That battle rapper.
Yeah.
80 of those bitches in my fucking fruit loops.
I think a rush at one point in time was taking something like 90 a day,
but that's the same thing.
The Lambo.
Oh,
I thought you meant the progressive rock band.
They progressive.
They're classic.
It's not what they're called.
I think that's called prog rock rush Canada.
The steam approaches.
How could that be progressive?
Is it,
is that what you're thinking?
Is Jamie progressive?
I mean,
I don't know what that means.
I've been around for it.
I guess it's just their smart isn't progressive.
I don't think it means that they're forward thinking.
I think it means that they,
their music progress's am I right or something like that.
Hmm.
Okay.
Too many uses of the word progressive and provincial.
Yeah.
Well,
progressive more provincial.
I was,
I was just fucking that up.
You're saying that there's a million different ways you can use the word
progressive.
Well,
this too.
You know,
like progressing forward and progressive as far as an ideology.
Right.
Those two are not,
you know,
like progressive music.
I don't know.
I don't really understand music,
but I would imagine you're saying as far as like how the courts progress,
you know,
all I know about his progressive house,
which is that it will progress from being bad music to being worse.
I think it's just a joke folks.
More aggressive with being bad.
Yeah.
The,
um,
did you,
is these those pills man?
Huh?
What are these?
Right here.
Ah,
that's something different.
It's a game.
What is that?
That's not Ivor gay.
What the fuck are these pills?
Are these yours?
Yeah,
that's just that sport tech.
Shroom tech.
She can't even talk.
He has to laugh.
No,
but it is from tech medicine check.
Okay.
Oh,
it really is.
Why is it in a little Baggie?
So sketchy dude,
you're literally more sketchy than that rap battle rapper dude.
Completely sketching it.
He's completely sketching what we're in the middle of talking about it.
Um,
I have a game drug addiction.
We've gotten past Oh,
progressive.
The idea of progressive music as opposed to progressive,
like thinking and progressive because progressive becomes like left wing,
you know,
like become interchangeable.
Progressive and liberal.
Oh right.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
it's more like people think of it as more like,
like a conservative person when I have a very different idea of what progressive
thinking is.
Oh,
it's obnoxious to call yourself progressive.
Yeah,
we're the progressive ones.
Yeah.
Where the wise ones and then there's the other side,
the dumb people.
But I do think they're done well.
They are definitely dumber.
You know,
it's just little words are a problem,
you know,
labeling things or problem because as soon as you label something,
you can define things in a way like you know,
Oh you liberal.
Like you know,
arguments where someone will go,
well liberals like you.
Like do you,
do you actually know what the word liberal means?
It's probably a good thing.
Let's look up.
Liberal liberal is most often thought of as being like bleeding hard or soft or
you know,
someone who's weak or has a delusional view.
Philosophical view.
That's the negative way of thinking about a liberal,
a adult.
Yeah.
Adult and adult,
but look,
look at the word in the dictionary.
A favorable to progress or reform as in political or religious affairs so that
we are progressive.
Yeah.
Or I am you are liberal noting or pertaining to a political party.
Okay.
Of pertaining to,
not based on advocating liberalism but there's like some,
okay.
Here.
Favorable or in accord with the concepts of maximum individual freedom possible
especially as guaranteed by law and secured by governmental protection of civil
liberties.
That's something that sounds good.
It sounds good to me,
but he say that being a liberal it just think about that you're saying being
liberal,
you're mocking someone for being a liberal,
that it's not good to be favorable to the concept of maximum individual freedom,
especially as guaranteed by law and secured by governmental protection of civil
liberties.
You don't not into that.
Well that's kind of complicated because then the,
you know the extreme right wing on the libertarian side,
those people are essentially liberals themselves.
Yeah.
They are dudes that are out like fighting the BLM in Nevada.
I mean,
sounds the weird racism stuff.
The Bundy ranch,
that dude is really all about the extreme notion of personal civil liberties as
liberal as possible.
The government shouldn't ever have any say in anything except I don't know what
they think the government should do.
I don't know.
But he thinks that black people are better off as slaves.
Now he's got a point there and I'll tell you why.
From a liberal perspective.
Yeah,
that was a,
that was sort of the crumbling of his big ideologies.
Like,
and I'm a huge racist.
Well,
and the fact that he denied that he ever said it,
but they had a recording of it and they went back and played it back for him.
Like you,
you did say it.
You said that exactly.
It was,
this is not what I meant.
Tmo I mean,
I seen him,
a couple of black people that would be better off as slaves.
I would,
I just might talked to a couple of dudes and they said,
and is his perspective,
was it as driving through Las Vegas and he saw bad neighborhoods in Vegas and
then he started talking about,
you know,
how much better they would be off of.
They were picking cotton like wow.
Yeah,
on a plantation.
Like um,
no,
not,
I think your perspective's a little fucked up dude and don't show some taxes
bitch.
How about paying those taxes?
I don't believe in taxes raising taxes,
but what,
here's a question.
Do you think that I'm crazy ucs murder man?
What do you think a person like that,
do you think that he would've gained from an Iowaska experience or would it just
make him crazy?
It's a good question.
I don't think anyone really knows until you take someone like that and give it
to them.
Otherwise you're just guessing.
Not Enough people who've actually done it.
Certainly not enough psychotics who've done it,
you know?
And the other thing is it's illegal in America,
so you have to go to Peru to do it or you've got to do it under the cover of
darkness here in America.
Very hard to convince that.
Got To go to Peru on a psychological experiment.
Well,
he obviously was a very troubled human being.
Anybody that could possibly do that,
anybody can get in their car and just randomly shoot people.
Did he shoot himself at the end?
It seems like he did.
They haven't announced that.
Right,
but he was dead of a gunshot wound inside of his car.
It seemed like such a spoiled Brat that,
that that I want to know if,
how much is it like him being like crazy and how much of him like growing up in
like some weird Cinderella type life that he wants,
he didn't get something immediately that easy that he just couldn't handle it.
That's the thing.
I was reading a lot of people,
you know,
that we're sort of deriding the idea that we're calling him crazy.
And they were saying,
you know,
basically when a Muslim person bloat,
kills a bunch of people,
we start talking about uh,
the calling them terrorists when,
uh,
when,
you know,
uh,
a black dude kills a bunch of people.
We started calling them thugs,
but when a young white guy starts killing people,
we call the mentally ill.
And somehow that's,
there's some inherent hypocrisy in that.
And I kind of just think like,
it's,
I was thinking about this last night,
like there's,
there's levels of human evil that are so intense that what we get when we
approached some,
we just kind of like shut down.
Like,
you know,
remember the matrix when they would do like the electronic pulse and all the
machinery would just shut down.
It's like there are levels of human evil that we get to that are so intense that
when we start approaching them,
thought just drops out and pee.
And it's all emotion that's left.
And so you can look at somebody like that.
And say,
you know,
it's a hypocritical to call that guy mentally ill or you're fighting against a
feminist cause by not recognizing the inherent misogyny and his attack.
But really what's happening is something so much sadder and deeper than either
of those things.
It's just like we're living in this insane fucking world where human beings have
some tick in this country,
more than another countries.
No one can figure out why were they sometimes once in a while we'll go into a
place and shoot a bunch of people and no one knows why it happens.
And some people say it's because it's mental illness.
And some people say it's because of bad parenting.
And some people say it's because of gun control.
And some people say it's because of,
you know,
violent video games and violent men and MMA and movies and music.
And nobody fucking knows why it's really happening.
And it's so terrifying that we just start slinging mud at one another.
Trying to,
trying to say,
well,
it's this,
it's that.
And you're part of the problem by perpetuating this idea.
And the reality is,
is existence is terrifying and humans are fucking weird.
And once in a while there's this evolutionary blip that somebody pops out of
their mother with a,
you know,
sort of genetic code ready to murder people.
And I don't think it's because of being spoiled and maybe it is,
and I don't think it's because of,
you know,
chemical imbalances or maybe it is,
it's just the reality is that's what's happening is jack the ripper exists in
some 0.001% of human beings.
It's terrifying.
It's a small percentage,
but there's so many people that when our access to news and information is so
complete now than anytime something happens anywhere in the world,
that's bad.
We get to hear about it.
And the numbers,
if you look at it and try to put it into perspective,
when you're talking about 7 billion people,
like you hear about a horrible gang rape in India and everybody at home just
clutches or chest and rightly so,
you freak out.
You think,
what if that was a loved one would?
If that was me,
you know God,
what is wrong with humanity that a bunch of people on a bus can rape some woman?
The numbers though of people not raping and not murdering or the more shocking,
it's like we concentrate on the negative and look entirely at these people like
this one fuck up his crazy ass hole shot a bunch of people in Santa Barbara.
The number of people that don't really define human behavior.
So I ideas of human behavior oftentimes are shaped in this scared way by these
instances that are extremely rare in perspective.
If you put it into perspective that the the great number of people,
you know,
great number of people you know are not going to commit violence.
They're not going to rape and not going to murder,
they're not going to do anything.
It's just knowing that it does exist within those numbers.
The perspective gets sort of skewed because if you go to CNN at any point in
time,
it's like that old bill Hicks bit.
Remember that Bill Hicks bet he did about a watching CNN,
AIDS,
murder,
death pit bulls.
He goes,
and then you open any door Chirp,
Chirp,
chirp.
Like what the fuck is all this shit?
You know,
like if someone needs to get Ted Turner,
the,
you know,
Jane Fonda's not fucking Ted Turner.
So He's,
he's putting up a,
everybody will die of AIDS by 1990 print it,
you know,
he had that bit and um,
it's kind of true.
If you go to CNN right now,
what do you get?
You get the first thing is six killed in Santa Barbara.
Rampage three shot dead in myrtle beach.
I mean,
yeah.
You know,
this billionaire says he won the Ukraine election,
Egypt campaigner worker slain.
I mean,
it's all murder,
murder,
murder.
But there is a lot of murder.
There's a lot of murder,
but there's a lot of people,
right?
There's 7 billion fucking people,
350 million in America.
There's so many,
so many to be the actual amount of people that kill people.
When something like this happens,
if you looked at a giant map of all the human beings and all the human beings,
we're like a little red dot and every now and then a murder went off.
Fuck,
it's,
it's a small amount.
It's a really tiny,
tiny,
tiny amount.
But what's interesting about us is that all of us know we're not supposed to
murder people.
We all,
you know what I mean?
Like that's a part of the human thing is that the difference between the human
and the animal is that we were born with this consciousness of what,
you know,
good and the good and evil,
whatever that is.
But we have these sort of notions,
don't fuck kids,
don't kill humans,
don't rape people.
We all know that information and yet we keep doing it.
It's is it just because we're animals,
but again,
would the numbers of people that actually do do those things,
rape kids murder and do fucked up horrible robberies.
There's are so small and almost all of it.
Like if you look at all these people that are committing terrible crimes,
like what's the one thing they have in common?
Alienation.
Alienation is one of the big ones.
A lot of these people feel alienated.
A lot of these people feel like they're outside is,
a lot of these people hate all these other people.
They associate other people with giving them pain.
They feel like they're out.
They don't,
you know,
they don't have anybody that you know,
they feel like they're connected to.
They're all fucked up on psychotropic drugs.
They're all fucked up on life itself though they're there,
they're not in the hive and this,
one of the things that's weird about people is that we need other people.
We need him bad and you can't just take a person and feed them and give them
water and never have any human contact because they'll go crazy.
That's why they put people in solitary confinement.
They can't wait until somebody opens that slot so he could look at someone and
said hello to him.
I mean,
you need people.
It's part of the very human experience itself.
We're not individuals.
We're a part of a giant multi life organism.
The multi life organism is the human race and when someone doesn't fit in and it
all goes wrong.
If you ever play a video game and you're in the middle of like you're getting
your ass kicked and you just want to unplug the fucking box because your friend
is mocking you and you're like,
you're down like 200 to zero and you just keep getting killed,
your instinct is to shut it off.
Your instinct is to turn off the box.
A lot of people do that.
Kids do that all the time.
You Watch kids play games.
If they're losing really,
really badly,
they'll flip the fucking chess.
Okay.
Are you saying anger?
These people are shutting off the box.
Exactly.
That's what he's doing.
By driving around shooting a bunch of people then shooting himself,
he caused some pain and then end his own.
What's all in one thing?
What's the solution?
The solution is very complicated,
but it's,
it's a part of evolving as a race.
I think it's,
it's a part of what are we now and what did we used to be?
We used to be murderers,
fucking monkeys on rampages thrown rocks at other murderous monkeys.
Before that,
we were single celled organisms slopping around in the ocean.
I mean,
we've become something that has gotten us to this point,
but it's not done.
It's not done at all.
And how many these kind of conversations,
human beings having these kind of conversations,
it's not just you and I,
but people all over the world is slowly but surely elevating awareness.
And it's,
it's,
it's noticeable in our culture.
Like look at this,
this is a kind of a weird example,
but someone was talking about comedy in the 1980s they were talking about like
Eddie Murphy Raw.
And then if you watch Eddie Murphy Raw,
like you realize like how fucking homophobic it is and nasty it is and mean
spirited straight up.
Just mean like it's so a friend was,
he had it on and I forget who the fuck had told me.
[inaudible] professor really homophobic.
Really.
The nutty professor says,
how dare you,
that fart scene though.
But there's a bunch of things that you used to be able to do.
Uh,
and people got away with it and now people realize,
hey,
you know,
that's not fucking cool.
And it's become more and more not cool as time has gone on as more and more
people exchange information.
But the real,
the reality remains that there's a good percentage of people that fucking suck
and they're going to be sucky at parents too.
They suck at everything.
I had this person over the other day and I'm a friend of the family and,
uh,
we're,
we're talking about his childhood and in just this horrible parents,
parents,
horrible,
uh,
parental situation,
real bad drugs and alcohol and meanness and violence and all these different
things and just seeing this person who's gone through this and can kind of
express it,
but then you see him with his kid and he's great.
He's a great parent,
like super loving,
you know,
into it communicates a lot and you go,
okay,
well at least you know,
something happened.
It was a terrible situation,
but information was exchanged.
The,
this,
this person has evolved.
And then vendor dealing with this new person in their life,
this child that they had,
and they're doing a great job with it.
And so you see this sort of information being exchanged and lessons being
learned and lives being in Renton.
It's just like a,
as a,
as a human race,
as is this huge project of,
of evolution and growth.
We're getting better.
It's just not done.
It takes a long fucking time.
And you're going to have newt Gingrich still sitting around saying a bunch of
fucking stupid shit and you're going to have bill O'Reilly.
You're going to have these dinosaurs that were stuck in this old way of living
Donald Sterling.
You're going to have these old shitheads that there's still loafing around,
you know,
with this archaic idea of what the code of life is inside their head.
And you're going to have shit heads like this fucking evil kid that went around
shooting people in Santa Barbara because he was an outcast.
You're gonna have that.
We're not done yet.
And you know,
and maybe part of what's hurting us in the fact that we're not done is that
we're restricting a lot of these other options like Iowasca,
Ibogaine mushrooms,
all these different things that have had massively positive effects on some
people life changing effects.
Would it have helped that kid?
I don't know.
But it helps people.
It helps people way more than anything anybody's ever figured out as far as like
and going to meetings where you pray to donuts,
all that,
all that shit is cute.
But go see the wizard,
go ride on the fucking snake with Gandalf in the middle of the jungle and you'll
come back with a different perspective.
Just smoked the fairy dust,
go take some dn t and literally be shot to the center of the universe for 15
minutes and explore all the possible options for life itself.
It's all those things can help people.
And I don't know if it would've helped this kid,
this kid sent,
it seems like he's completely and totally fucked up,
but I think that he is one part of this giant fractal and when one part explodes
and blows up,
it doesn't change the beauty of the positive aspects of the fact that we just
have to figure out how to keep those blow ups at a minimum.
And a lot of it has to do with people raising kids.
They just do a fucking terrible job of it.
And it also could be,
you're around a bunch of other cunts,
you know,
maybe your neighbors,
all the kids you go to school with,
they're pieces of shit and they're fucking parents suck ass.
And so world's filled with suck,
you know,
and sometimes you can't,
you can't catch a break.
You just in a bad spot.
I wasn't,
I grew,
I had a bad neighborhood when I was 13 or when I was between 11 and when I was
13 we moved.
Um,
so I guess,
no,
between 11 and 13 I was in Florida.
13 to 14 is where it was bad.
That was when I was in Jamaica plain,
which is a bad neighborhood in Boston.
It's more gentrified now.
It's become sort of more of a hipster place where people bought places and fixed
him up.
But when I lived there in,
I guess it was like 79 something like that,
somebody who's 79 80 it was fucking terrible.
It's bad kids,
bad kids doing bad shit.
There was always,
people were breaking into people's houses left and right.
There's a lot of kids that would do B and e's and they would call them B and he
was like,
it was no big.
They themselves would call it that.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He got popped for me to go do a B and the,
and they had horrible accents.
There's a kid named Holly Hudson lived next door.
You couldn't trust that care for five seconds.
He was always trying to steal things.
They were just,
they were drinking.
There were 11 he's listening right now.
Weeping.
He's dead.
He's not lifting.
Yeah.
I remember following,
he was a creepy next door neighbor,
but the,
but the point is that I was stuck.
I mean it was only for about a year and a half till my parents realize this is a
terrible place to be.
And then we moved to a suburb called Newton,
which is the total opposite.
Nice families,
real like fucking Mayberry type town.
But a Jamaica plain was tricky.
And if I had stayed in Jamaica plain,
if I was in there,
ah fuck,
it's fucking hard to find cool people.
Hard to find safety,
you know,
hard to find.
Like I would leave my house and it would be sure that one of the neighbors would
break and I'll be sure like we caught people in the driveway trying to break
into cars.
Like there's just,
it was just,
just dangerous.
Just not good.
If that's your spot,
you fuck man,
that's,
and that's the number one thing that shows you that this government and the
people that are in charge don't give a fuck about the human race as an idea.
Because if they did the number one thing that everybody would be concentrating
on horrible neighborhoods,
skid row,
they would go to skid row and they would go,
how the fuck can this exist in 2014 with what we forget all your personal
freedom stuff.
This is obviously a problem,
right?
So giant problem.
You got a fucking village of zombies.
Go to go to Compton,
go to the,
go to the ghetto,
go to go to watts,
go to the worst spots in Harlem.
Go there and go.
How is it still like this
in this country?
Believe in individual freedoms above the freedoms of the of the masses.
I mean,
you don't take person's freedom to help.
I'm just saying that the,
the,
the fundamental notion of America is due for yourself.
And the problem with looking at a neighborhood filled with people who are down
on their luck is that the,
the reaction in this country can be,
look at all,
look at all these poor people or look all their brands.
Look at all these lazy people that won't do what I did.
Look at me.
Look at my house.
I've got a wonderful house,
I've got a huge car.
Therefore a person can have a wonderful house and a huge car.
Therefore,
if you don't have a wonderful house and a used car,
you didn't do the things you needed to do to get it.
I,
I'm always struck with people that complain about being on welfare.
People on Welfare.
They are always people who I can tell have never encountered people on welfare.
I never see people that are like from neighborhoods where people grew up on
welfare going like these bucking welfare.
It's like,
it's always people from the suburbs that are talking about an it,
an abstraction and intellectual abstraction like the welfare people.
Then you go meet people and you go,
oh,
you're like a poor family.
It's a lot easier to talk about welfare.
Uh,
p Mama's when you've never met people that are moms that are trying to feed
their kids by getting food stamps.
Yeah.
I was on welfare when I was a kid,
so it was,
I was,
it's not what people think it is.
People that are,
there's people struggling.
There's sure there's people that abuse it.
You know,
you hear about them,
they still work and they have jobs and they still take welfare and even rich
people.
I've heard stories of rich people that somehow or another we had con the system
or getting welfare,
but it's not.
Money's not going to fix everything.
We were Jews going to fix anything.
Jews on welfare.
We were the first of our kind of,
that should be a band.
Yeah.
The name for a band.
We had a special entrance to the building and stuff.
Let us send the back.
You know you were the first with those RFID cards.
Yeah.
They'd saw her last name.
We're like,
are you sure you're in the right place?
I just think people suck at raising people and get you get stuck.
We get stuck in a bad pattern.
Super Common.
Like one of the most common things in life is for people to get stuck in bad
patterns.
I mean,
how many folks do we know that just have the same issues over and over again?
Whether it comes to girlfriends,
whether it comes to boyfriends,
whether it comes to jobs getting fired.
You're like,
how many fucking people this drives me,
God damn nuts.
And people always say,
well,
you know,
I've only gone to like a couple of weddings ever and one of the reasons being is
like I'm not going to go to,
you're obviously going to fail project if you're one of those motherfuckers.
Like I have a friend that I used to work with and he was super offended cause I
didn't go to his wedding and I was like,
dude,
I've seen you through every one of your horrendous relationships.
You had a ton of fucking terrible relation with them.
They all went bad.
They all just come.
Just obvious bad choices from the jump.
And you've been with this chick for a year and you want me to fly to New York?
Fuck you man.
You're being rude,
rude ass.
Why do your ridiculous party,
the invitation said we'll attend,
will not attend,
do not believe in the longterm viability of this relationship.
Well just all of it.
Like standing there,
standing,
staring in your best clothes,
waiting for some people to say some nonsense to each other.
Like this is crazy,
but you're married.
It's crazy.
I'm married and the only reason why I'm married because my wife wants marriage.
She likes it and I love her enough that I'm willing to do something retarded.
That's what I did.
But the idea by asking,
yeah,
that's exactly what I said it.
But the idea of asking someone to go and stand there and watch you do your
fucking ceremony and hold hands and look at each other and slip metal on each
other's fingers like God damn,
you need that much attention.
If you guys really want to do it,
do it yourself.
Go somewhere.
And you know if you really want to see,
I'm not,
I'm not against ceremony.
I'm not against someone doing the Oh,
but we want our loved ones around like Ben.
She want people to fly to where you're at because it makes you the fucking King
of the hour.
It makes you super special.
It makes you the fucking,
this is the number one reason why we're here.
Everyone knows why we're here.
It's all for Mike.
Clink clink here,
here.
Let's have a toast to Mike.
It's people that want to feel fucking special.
Well and the even further on the absurdity of marriage is the whole gay marriage
argument is flawed in its beginning because it's like,
why are we involving the government in marriage in the first place?
Why do you go register your love with the government and then go basically all
you do when you get married and register with the government is saying it's
going to be,
I want to make sure it's incredibly difficult for us to break up.
Okay,
if this doesn't work out,
I want to make sure the government is somehow involved in,
are separating.
Okay.
I've,
I actually understand gay marriage more than I understand straight marriage
because gay people like being gay.
If you're going to fully go gay and you're going to be out and we all know that
a lot of people who are gay or not out there like,
hi,
they're in the closet.
If you're gay and you're married to another gay dude,
damn,
he's all in.
That guy's all in.
He went in publicly and financially when he didn't even have to,
they can't get pregnant.
They can't get pregnant.
Like you could fuck till the end of time.
That person could never keep you there.
You can never say,
you know what I'm going to raise your child would have all your responsibility,
bro.
I carried your fucking baby for nine months inside me.
I love your gay accent by the way.
That's my new,
my new gay motherfucker who it's like a whole Cogan bro.
Ish.
What are you going to do when I divorce you?
I'm giving birth.
That's just to give a shit.
Yeah,
well I don't think they shit,
they'd just have a different opening sort of taint.
Shoot with a baby comes out,
but they're all in,
you know?
I mean that's,
that's really all in and they don't have to be,
that's a big commitment.
If you gain,
you decide to get married anyway.
Like wow,
that's a commitment.
That's a commitment and them as a motherfucker.
And another thing that happens with the gay people is a lot of times is
fascinating when they get married,
they assume traditional roles like male and female roles.
Like,
I have friends that are gay and they're married and they lived down the street
and there's like that the guy's one guy's clear with the husband and one guys
clear the wife,
you know,
it's like,
it's pretty clear.
One Guy Works,
the other one doesn't.
They have a kid that they've adopted and they're raising,
this kid is fed very fascinating situation,
but they have almost the sort of nuclear family,
but they have it with two men.
Do you think that's typical but it doesn't seem typical to me.
The one person is uh,
you know,
roles.
Many times I've seen the pie.
I think it's a Yin Yang sort of situation.
I think it's an opposite.
Attract sort of a situation.
Is that the name of the kid they adopted?
No,
he,
no way.
You can't adopt white kids.
You out of here.
If you have money,
you can get a white one.
Actually,
I feel like the white ones are probably worse because they're all from these
horrifying like cobwebby like Gulag,
uh,
you know,
orphanages,
where they sat up straight for like the first five years of their life.
You know,
and they look all nice and white and then you've got them home and they're like,
I've,
it'll break you all Avi and drag out.
The problem is no one touched him for a year.
Maybe with collide they would ignore him.
Yeah,
no,
I'd rather,
I'd rather have a nice,
you know,
touched African babies
then some eastern European blonde,
good looking baby that's never been touched.
Psycho future MMA superstar.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I could see that.
Um,
well,
you know,
I think people have a natural inclination to be attracted to opposites in a way,
not fully opposite,
but some aspects like I think sometimes like a stronger personality would like a
more submissive personality or the opposite or vice versa,
like submissive men,
like a dominant overbearing woman or you know,
but then I have friends that are very similar and they get along great too.
He said,
it doesn't matter.
Isn't the cliche though that somebody who a very powerful man,
we'll want to dominate tricks,
you know,
beat him up and shit on his chest or whatever.
Really super true.
Like A,
I knew a woman who was a dominatrix and she would,
uh,
professionally beat the fuck out of these really rich guys.
She'd kicked him in the Dick and step on them with high heels and leave marks
all over and with their belt and like beat them and tag them and pee on them.
She would do all kinds of crazy shit to them.
Nothing about that.
Sounds pleasant to me.
She would,
she'd be the master.
That was part of the thing.
She's like,
I had to be,
I had to be the master.
Like for them it was like an opportunity that they can completely relinquish.
And I goes,
it just playing a role like,
like do you think that he gets snapped at anytime and go,
no,
you fucking shut up.
You know?
And she's like,
no,
no.
They just,
they give into it willingly.
It's really amazing.
It's almost like they need it.
So it's like a service that she provides and it's always these like high powered
CEOs with their teeny little,
I imagine have teen low penises,
fat penises.
They're thick.
The know,
like they're teeny,
but there's like fat that's like,
oh,
sure.
Right,
right,
right.
Under a fat dude.
Do you know about that?
No.
It's where your belly stick out further than your Dick to ah,
yeah,
I could see like a rob Ford type,
but with not that person.
He said,
look,
two Alpha but personality and he's got that body Jason Alexander.
Yeah,
sure.
Absolutely.
And he's got his tie still on the little bit,
you know,
and it's like Pudgy,
sort of like a filo dough type of skin,
like popping out of the space between,
with his pants around his ankle that she kicks him in the Dick and he
a little urine bottom,
like a pig bottom.
That's right.
Yeah.
Like some sort of like weird chest hair situation.
Definitely with asymmetrical like asymmetrical chest hair.
Like the left one has more hair on the right one,
just a little fat dick and,
but he's all rich and stuff because of his little Dick.
He went to business school,
master shut,
pees on his face,
shut the fuck up.
I knew a guy that he would,
um,
he would,
I think was,
I don't know if there was a woman with a man,
but one of them would lay underneath a glass table while the one shit on top of
the class day.
They told me they told you they did.
It could be not true.
I don't know.
I wasn't there watching,
but it seemed dynamically correct.
Like their dynamic was real intense.
Like he was like a big goal.
Like psycho,
you know,
one of those,
those guys that seem like they could have started a cult if they were born in it
in a different,
a slightly different era with a little bit more money.
They would have started a call.
It was like that type of dude.
Wow.
And she was like all sex workery and stuff.
Really?
Yeah.
What did he do for a living?
I can't,
he was a musician.
Oh yeah.
It was a strange,
strange,
strange man.
Interesting.
A lot of very weird people out there.
This is a lot of very weird people here in la.
Oh,
the weirdest.
This is the weirdest spot because this is the spot where they think they're
going to finally get that attention that they deserve and sexually weird.
There's a lot of weird sex in it and in La.
I have one on here,
man.
Come on.
Me Talking about what are you doing?
Well,
I'm in a relationship now,
but uh,
I was very much,
I'll tell you,
I got some good stories.
Okay,
please.
This is,
this is a pretty good one.
Oh,
well I want to tell you though.
Okay.
Well,
one,
when I was starting to hit bottom,
I've gotten that some issues with sex,
but one real bad story was I,
there was a girl,
I was,
I went to this clothing store and I used to be really in a big girl,
so very big girls.
How big,
I mean as big as you can muster.
Hundred plus I was into at all.
Yeah,
I like a thick girl anyway,
but my girl now is not very small,
but the deal with it.
No,
I love her and she's great and she's hot.
If we were in ski clothes,
sometimes I'll feed her a lot.
You know those relationships where there's a feeder?
Do you know about that?
No,
this is like where,
where the fat thing that goes,
it goes beyond just like a,
like I think it's hot and into like a,
like a fetish.
So there'll be a guy like me,
like a skinny kind of weekly and guy that's like bringing his fat girlfriend
like Twinkies and,
and,
and Ho Hos and roast beef and stuffing and just be like,
here honey,
you keep eating.
And she gets bigger and bigger.
So there's like a feeder and then there's like a big woman that just eventually
I guess grows and grows and grows and his erection grows with or something like
that.
Oh,
what now this relationship is defined.
Like when you say there's a type,
like this is defined like websites where they talk about this.
I mean you could look that up.
I mean I'm not a,
but is it like a,
is there a community?
Well,
yeah,
I don't know if there's a community because they have to bring,
they have to get,
it's hard to get that many cranes to bring people to the meetings.
And what I mean like an online community where this is all discuss.
I'm sure beers.
Yeah.
No,
this is a real thing.
Have you heard of it?
I've never heard of that.
Have you been trying this with your new girl?
No,
no,
no I'm not.
I was never like that for me was,
I mean this is like a weird psychological,
like I'm going to bring you food.
It's being dominated by one person that's passive.
I think the,
you know,
the,
the dominatrix in this case doesn't even have to do anything but sit around and
eat,
you know?
That's interesting.
But anyway,
I don't know why I even brought that up.
That's weird sex stuff.
So this person was,
was big and I went to the store,
she was the,
she was the parking attendant at the store and this is like,
well into comedy.
So I'm okay on some level of public figure.
I mean,
not like a huge public figure,
but enough that it's like,
I shouldn't be like at random approach.
Maybe I should,
who knows.
Anyway,
this girl,
she was bigger and she was the parking lot of tenant at this store.
And I somehow started talking to her and got her phone number and then sort of
texting with her.
And this is so I remember I had a show that night in Orange County.
I was at a,
um,
a comedy show at UC Irvine.
And I brought my friend Jacob Jacob sear off down to the,
down to the show.
And,
uh,
and she was texting with me while I was at the show in Orange County and was
like,
Oh,
you should've said something.
You know,
I would have sucked your dick in the parking lot.
And I was like,
oh,
really?
All activated,
like a little Dick Getting hard like that Rob Ford Guy,
you know,
and uh,
and she's like,
yeah,
I mean,
you know what,
you come by my house tonight.
I'll suck your dick tonight.
And I was like,
I was like,
where do you live?
And she's like,
Compton and I,
and I started doing the math and I'm like,
okay,
Orange County,
if I'm driving back to my home in silver lake,
Compton is sort of in a weird way on the way.
So I,
I fucking get rid of Jacob,
you know,
I go,
I say to some other comic like,
can you please give it a checkup,
a boat ride home?
I've got an erection right now.
And uh,
like,
uh,
okay.
Like I don't tell anybody what's going on.
My friend,
my good friend Jacob,
he's like,
why are you sloughing me off on this stranger?
Who's going to give him a ride home?
I was like,
and he's got some business to take care of it.
It's like,
it's 1130 at night.
What?
But he's a pervert too.
So I'm driving,
I pull off the exit and Compton where this girl says she's going to suck my dick
and I start driving through Compton and it's getting weirder and weirder and
worse and worse the further I go and I keep texting her and she's like,
keep going,
keep going.
And I pulled down this alley and it's like an abandoned alley and it's like,
it's like you want to talk about having two different brains.
You know what I mean?
Like I knew my brain,
my good brain,
my big brain was telling me like your going to be murdered.
This is a situation where you're,
I'm driving down an alley.
There's an empty field on one side,
there's like tract housing on the other side.
Like it's,
there's no street lights.
She's,
and she keeps going.
Keep going,
keep going.
I'm at the end of the,
at the end of this alley I'm waiting for you.
Keep going.
I just know I'm going to get there.
Her brothers are going to come out,
surround the car.
Dude,
I'm dead.
My car's dead.
And I keep driving forward because I have this other brain that's like this.
A little Ayp,
Bonobo brain that's going like the end of this road.
There's a blow.
Keep track of a weights.
I swear you couldn't.
There is no place in la that's more well suited to murder a white person then
this alley.
Wow.
So how's it going down?
She comes outside,
take a deep breath,
she gets in the car and she gives me a blow job.
And
when you came,
was it like the most like sneaky coming ever?
Like oh good,
good,
good.
The ignition was already on.
Oh,
the other crazy thing is she lives in,
she lives in Compton.
One of the first thing she says before she starts giving me head is uh Oh yeah,
I love sucking Dick.
I'll suck anybody's dick except for,
and then she just drops an end bomb like a heart.
And I'm like,
you live in Compton's and my other,
again,
two brains,
my brain is like,
don't comment on the racism.
Don't comment on the racism shit.
Come on.
She's about to give you a blowjob.
Don't even,
and I didn't,
I focused,
I focused up through it.
Wow.
Was that the last time you saw her?
Yeah,
that's the last time I saw it.
Did you change your phone number?
I,
wait,
I'm lying to you.
No,
I changed my,
I raced the phone number,
uh,
and told her I have a girlfriend now.
It didn't have a girlfriend.
I have a girlfriend now raced her phone number.
Then I w like maybe six months later I drove by that place again.
God or phone number again.
Started texting with her and then I've raced her phone number and never,
I never went back.
She was big.
She was like two to 50 probably.
Since you've been with a lot of big girls.
Uh,
yeah.
Have you ever had any kind of cleaning problems where they smell more like poop
or does that get you like a bigger boner when you smell that?
Cause I mean they don't smell the best is a serious question about that.
It seems like a serious question.
He's throwing Ibogaine at me as he asks for that.
Um,
no.
I mean,
you know people fat people shower.
Yeah.
Okay.
But I hear what you're saying.
They can't get all those nooks and crannies of,
you're talking about the big 50 is not that big bro.
Yeah.
I mean I'm talking about like five hundreds and Ralphie may size.
I know I have fucked her off.
He may refer him is a good guy to fuck.
Yeah,
I bet he is.
Actually you guys,
there was another girl when I first moved to town that she was like,
uh,
she was like a kind of,
she was real intense.
Speaking of power dynamics,
she was,
she's a kind of girl.
She kept going like,
put your cigarette out on me,
put your cigarette out on this Christ.
And I was like,
I can't,
I don't,
I don't think I can do that.
And she would be like,
she was very aggressive and pain oriented and she was biting me and like biting
my Dick and biting my balls.
Oh God.
But it was also hot,
but also I didn't like the biting part and be like,
oh,
stop out.
And uh,
at one point she doesn't called Jewish like that now stop out.
And at one point she looks down,
she's like going down.
I mean,
she stops and she goes,
what is that?
And you know,
the kind of,
what is that the way you would say?
Like if you were going down on a girl and you saw like a,
some sort of sore or something.
And I'm like,
what?
And I look and there is a contusion,
like a straight up like bubbles,
blood blister on my scrotum from her biting you from her bite.
I say,
you fucking did that and she's,
and then afterwards she was like,
that was great.
We should do it again.
And I texted her,
I was like,
I don't know.
I think you maybe play it a little too rough for me.
And she goes,
uh,
okay.
She's like,
no,
like all dial it back.
No like,
oh,
let's try.
It was just like,
if you can't fucking ride the dragon with the scales that I have,
then get off.
God Damn Man,
Jesus Christ.
I got more.
Have you ever had the color like the next day where you're like,
why is my back and you just look on your back and he's just like,
Oh yeah,
I've had that,
but that's sort of normal.
That's girls just getting caught up in the throes of passion.
That's tight.
That seems good.
That's why I ramping down.
You're screwed.
I had other,
I had,
I've had sexual,
I don't know if you've,
you don't seem like you've had,
because you seem like you've been having fun sex experiences your whole life.
What makes you say that?
Just like,
you know,
you're like good looking and you've been,
you've been famous for a long time and it's,
you feel like,
you think this only fun sex that well,
no.
What?
I feel like,
I feel like you're the type of dude that likes to have sex only with good
looking women.
Yeah,
I'm crazy like that.
Yeah.
You're lucky to have her in a sexual deviant and that way.
No,
but there's like,
for me,
I used to get off on like hooking up with people that were not as a truck.
I,
it was hot purpose.
It was hot,
you know?
I would find hot to them.
Yeah.
And I would find a objective attractiveness in people that weren't objectively
attractive.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
So,
okay.
So what we were talking about earlier,
like that's your,
your kink.
So like the drug thing,
whatever led you to be an impulsive drug person led you for a while to be an
impro impulsive sex person.
So wasn't even almost a natural sort of attraction.
Like,
wow,
that's a pretty girl.
She likes me.
I like her,
I love her personality.
You didn't even like her personality.
She's talking about dropping bombs for one second
mega decks.
She said,
you'll like us still.
There's something about you that's hot.
Interestingly enough though,
I actually have,
oh yeah,
it's real big and black.
But where it was a shocker to her.
Yeah,
she was really bummed.
But
there was a guy with a slight trauma
everyday,
look where I live.
Uh Yeah,
no,
for sure.
That became the thing.
And it also is very compartmentalized.
I would be like in a store.
I remember one instance in particular was at this store at like two o'clock in
the morning shopping for,
I was at Safeway getting some groceries and this woman walked around the corner
and she was big and in the way that I liked and I started,
I did you ever get like,
have you ever gotten so horny you start getting cold?
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Little shivery I,
I'm not even flirting with this woman.
She's just a woman's shopping at two in the morning for fucking cheese whiz or
whatever.
And I'm like,
I gotta figure out a way to,
can you imagine if I walked up to her with a shivering like a two in the
morning?
Like,
Hey,
how are you?
There's no way she's fucking mate.
That's go so crazy.
Cause it's just cause she's big or something.
Yeah.
Something.
What else could it be if it wasn't the big thing?
No,
I guess you're right.
It's a big,
I mean that's when it would get the most pronounced.
It was pretty intense.
Wow.
That's amazing.
I've had sex where I lie sold after the woman left cause he thought I was
rational.
You thought it was rational?
No,
cause I know she was like scratching this area of her body.
When she left I was like freaked out so hard.
But I went into my bathroom,
I started Lysol with my legs like shape and then dish soap and then salt.
And the next day I,
speaking of 12 step meetings,
I went to my first and only sex addicts anonymous meeting.
I was just like,
something's got to change
to look at your face was awesome.
But you know there's no,
there's very little way for you to convince yourself that you're just like a
young man swinging around,
having a good time,
engaging in the regular sexuality of all human beings.
When you're spraying Lysol.
I'm
like,
how do you,
oh that's awesome.
So I went and one of the things about s sex,
well the first thing I realized when I got to a sex addicts anonymous meeting is
I may have a problem or something.
I may have a compulsive sexuality,
but I don't have what these people have.
I mean,
there was something else that they're talking about.
What were they talking about?
They were talking about,
I'll look,
I'll start looking at pornography at 4:00 PM and then all of a sudden the sun
will be coming up.
Whoa.
And I was like,
oh.
Or like I,
I had a home,
but I took all of my money and spent it on prostitutes,
you know,
that kind of thing.
Wow.
It was very intense.
It was stuff that I did not really fully relate.
Well,
there's definitely mental illnesses that are connected to weird sexual behavior.
Like there was an,
an episode of this podcast that I talk about all the time.
My new favorite podcast is radio lab.
Oh yeah,
sure.
Great podcast is really good,
amazing stuff.
Really interesting and fascinating subjects.
And it's always food for thought.
And they had one about a guy who had epilepsy and just fascinating.
So he was having all these tumors and they offered a surgery to fix this,
uh,
not tumors.
Um,
seizures rather.
And e they offered a surgery to fix the seizures and he accepted it.
And when they gave him the surgery,
it turned him into this weird sex addict who wanted food all the time,
wanted sex all the time,
but could not stop downloading pornography child including child pornography.
Yeah.
And could,
he would erase it and they would download it again and erase it.
And the way the neurologist described it is the area of his brain that was
removed literally is the area that controls impulsive decisions when it comes to
sexuality and needs and,
and any,
any desires there.
There's a part of all of us that like,
you know,
like think Barbara has a joke about it,
but you ever see a role,
people in the street and you drive and you go ahead and just fucking could turn
right now and are all these people over.
Like everybody's had those thoughts.
We,
no one ever does anything but like me,
I would see like a really frail old person and I would say I could just kick
this guy's head right off of his body just out of nowhere.
Just kick his head.
Right.
And I would not do it ever.
I would never even think about doing it.
But the thought is I bet that I could do that.
I bet I just,
we'll kick this guy in the head out of nowhere.
Imagine if you're like a hundred year old man.
You just,
I always think about
I leaping like you kick it with my do.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Just across a room.
And then I tried to someone just to see what everybody else would be doing.
We'll do like what did he,
why,
what the
right,
but you would never do it.
And that's the idea is that we all,
because people have good decision making capabilities and because people have
ethics and morals and you know,
and because you're nice,
you never do anything bad like that,
but that these thoughts are just,
they can come in your head randomly and why,
why do they come up?
Because you know that is a possibility that in some weird bizarro universe,
somebody might punch this old guy for no reason or that somebody might turn
their car into a crowd and stomp on the gas.
It's,
it is.
So you don't really think about doing it,
but you think that could be something that someone does,
but this poor fucking guy was doing things like he was like,
he couldn't help well with the child pornography.
Yeah.
Well the,
the part that what they said was the part that they removed from him was the Po,
the regulated,
that phone when you had the thought,
then your next thought is,
well of course I shouldn't,
we all kick this old man's head because that would be a mean thing to do and I
would go to jail and that's wrong.
But there's literal biological mass in your brain that is the part that tells
you that second thought,
which is don't do that.
So this guy's went away and it a regulated sexual compulsivity
yeah.
And,
and,
and hunger as well.
Right.
It's designed for,
remember that part?
Yeah.
They were talking about just hate,
like a wild man.
Just couldn't stop eating.
Um,
but the weird thing was,
and this is why they,
the judge recognized that the neurologist is correct.
If there was an issue in this guy had to deal with it,
but they still sentence him to jail because he didn't have anything on his
computer at work who's able to control himself at work and not in the rest of
his life.
So it showed some sort of a possibility of control.
Yeah.
I thought I found that to be fascinating.
It is pretty fascinating because I agree with it and sort of a weird way,
but he knew that they were there because what the thing was,
it wasn't just that he downloaded pornography is that he paid for it,
and by showing that he paid for it,
it's even worse because then you're supporting child pornography.
Right.
The other thing I thought was really fascinating was the part afterwards where
they started saying,
wow,
isn't that interesting that these kinds of aberrations could be caused by just a
biological,
literal physical hardware of your brain,
and this brain doctor came on.
It was the second guy afterwards.
I don't know if you remember this part,
and he was like,
that's what everything is.
Every thing,
every climb,
every behavior,
every positive thing,
your comedy.
Some that kids murder.
It's all biological.
It's all from the in moment you're born,
you're born and this thing happens or,
or this kind of chemical dump happens in your brain.
There's nothing that's occurring that isn't biological.
No human behavior isn't directly related to the biology of your brain.
So that kid,
so that dude looking at child pornography and that kid in,
in Santa Barbara,
all of those are related to the biological realities of that kid's brain,
of those people's brains.
And that therefore this person started saying this was the craziest part.
He,
they were saying,
well then shouldn't we,
should we let a person off because of what happened?
So we let the person off from going to prison because of what happened in their
brain's biologically.
And he was saying that's the wrong question because all crimes and all behaviors
as a result of what's happening in your brain biologically.
So the way that we should convict people of crimes is how likely they are based
upon their biology to commit a crime again is literally like time crimes or
whatever crime that's like minority report type shit.
Exactly.
And he's literally saying,
you can look at it,
you can say,
this guy's brain does this,
this,
and this.
He's therefore this likely to,
uh,
to recommit a crime.
Therefore he should go to prison for this amount of time.
Wow.
How sketchy.
Well,
that actually,
I actually think that that is something that could happen in the foreseeable
future.
Everybody talks about these mass shootings and they go,
oh,
well it's mental illness.
That's the problem.
The problem,
you know,
it's especially people that don't want to deal with,
whether or not gun control should be in this conversation.
And we'll say,
well,
it's mental illness.
We should focus on mental illness.
But the problem is there's no way to focus on mental illness as it pertains to
mass shootings.
You can't go up to a crazy person and say,
you seem crazy.
You go to the comedy store any night of the week and go and you just round up
like you know the the craziest 5% and then go,
they seem like they might shoot someone and there's no way to know until the
shooting someone and they go,
oh,
they were crazy enough to shoot someone.
I mean,
how can you look at a crazy person and think,
oh,
that guy's a shooter kind of crazy and not a harmless screamer on the street.
Kind of crazy person.
Yeah,
it's impossible.
The any,
anybody that doesn't want some sort of background checks on anybody that wants
to buy a weapon,
you a part of a huge problem.
Huge,
huge problem.
And the idea of is in the NRA idea is their philosophy,
I believe.
And it's not that they're not for any sort of checking,
but therefore a minimal amount of checking because they think that if you give
up a certain amount of rights that the government will never give those rights
back.
So they sit,
they stand and they dig their heels in the ground and they don't want anything
other than looser and more,
more freedom when it comes to drugs.
When it comes to guns,
rather like a Georgia,
the recent thing that they passed,
they uh,
they changed their gun laws and they made their gun laws like less restrictive
and people are freaking out.
Like I should probably Google exactly what it is.
Um,
but the uh,
people are just going nutty about these,
these gun laws.
Well this Elliot Guy,
he,
you know,
he bought his guns and he,
he also had 400 rounds of ammunition on him and he had also two psychiatrists.
So it seems like that should be information should have been shared with.
And also I just found his Twitter and you know how I was saying how he seemed
maybe cause he was so rich and stuff.
I had this like really good feeling of like American psycho.
You ever see that movie?
He had like the same kind of voice.
But look who is following on Twitter,
Hugo boss,
BMW Four Seasons Hotel and SB city college.
It's four frames.
Wow.
He was falling for people for Pete and Hugo boss.
He's into rich,
rich people thing.
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
it's,
it's really scary.
I'd be scared.
There's no way.
There is no way to know this kid.
There's a million kids.
Exactly.
Like that guy that never shoot people.
They just are crazy and make videos in their car and they even make videos.
By the way.
His parents called the police and said,
we think our kids going to do something crazy.
And the police came and investigated it and we're like,
well,
uh,
we'll,
we'll be back when your suit some people.
Yeah.
But the police didn't go,
okay,
your parents are worried psychiatrist.
Oh,
and we have you on record for buying 400 rounds of ammunition.
Maybe we should look further into this.
This is what,
this is what they changed in Georgia.
This is really fascinating.
And the idea is that itch it,
what it's gonna do is it's going to allow the people who have shown that they
have guns and uh,
and don't have never committed crimes with them,
that it protects the basic constitutional rights of the roughly 5% of Georgia
residency's who hold licensed to carry weapons.
It says that the law gives added protections to those who have played by the
rules and who can protect themselves from others from those who don't play by
the rules.
They said,
now this is,
this is what it allows them.
Broadly speaking,
they're saying,
um,
you're allowed to carry a gun in bars and associated parking facilities through,
through gun.
Though gun holders can be forced to leave upon notice by the property owner.
Government buildings going to be allowed to bring a gun into government
buildings.
Wow.
Places of worship.
Okay.
Only with the Express Pr,
uh,
approval.
Wow.
School safety zones,
school functions or on school provided transportation or brother.
That means a kid who's 18 years old who's a senior in high school who has a
license to carry a gun,
could carry a gun on the fucking school bus,
but by wrong,
if they start shooting,
you can revoke their permission to use the gun.
That's nice.
Excuse me.
Excuse me,
sir.
You're going to have to leave the bus and they'll immediately get up.
Bill expands the state stand,
your ground law aversion of which rose to prominence with the Trayvon Martin
case.
Wow.
You know what?
Fire Oh,
here it gets even crazier.
Firearm dealers are no longer a,
they'd no longer need to maintain records of sales and purchases for state
purposes.
That just seems arbitrary and terrible.
Why would you not want to have records of who's who's buying guns?
If someone is buying guns every week,
hey man,
you have a million guns.
Like what are you planning?
I mean,
I understand their point.
If you,
I always try with these,
with these issues to put my brain and the brain of the people that are making
the argument.
I guess I understand the point.
They really don't think that guns are the problem and they really think that
experimenting with gun control laws to try to solve a problem that isn't,
that isn't solvable through gun control,
we'll just all,
the only result it will have is that people's guns will get taken away.
And if you think that gun controlled won't solve any of these problems and it
just becomes you versus the government controlling your guns and look at these
fat white guys that are so happy that this law is getting signed.
Have you seen the pictures of the guys bringing in machine guns and into
chipotle a what?
You got to check that out.
It's because of this,
this law.
But it's just these like big virgin like call of duty type dudes would
literally,
I mean with straight up ar 15 is like strapped to their shoulders,
ordering to poet.
It's just like a weird,
just because they can now.
Yeah.
It's like a big customers not to bring their guns.
Pull it up,
put it up,
put on images cause there's
ridiculous.
I need to see that cue.
The backlash.
Oh we're so crazy.
See?
Oh Jesus.
There they are.
Look at that dude.
Look at the just absolute drought of Pussy that that guy has had in his life.
Look,
his gun,
his,
his penis.
I am never going to Atlanta.
Did you are chicken?
That's so crazy.
Look at his shoulder harness and everything.
God,
can you imagine going into topos lay and that's how that's going on.
Wow.
I can unfortunately,
I can imagine,
but you know what's weird about it is it is an American problem because I've
been to Israel a bunch and although Israel obviously has problems that are not
connected to gun control,
sending stuff,
leaving that issue aside
because of the sociopolitical realities of Israel.
People have guns all the time.
They're in restaurants or in synagogues.
Everybody has guns.
There's open carry everywhere and it doesn't feel weird and it doesn't,
there's not people shooting up random indiscriminate.
Yeah.
That's because they have a common enemy.
It could be because there is violence there all the time and that actually makes
it feel,
pardon me,
it makes sense.
When a Palestinian comes into Israel and shoots up a bunch of Israelis,
that terror makes sense because there's an ideology behind it as opposed to just
some random dude's firing into a,
into a school.
And so maybe it takes away the impulse of the Israeli people and the Palestinian
people to do indiscriminate violence.
But every time you start doing this,
like is it,
is it,
uh,
is it gun?
Too many guns?
We'll know because there are countries that have just as many,
many guns that aren't,
that don't have these indiscriminate shootings.
Is it because of violent video games will know because Japan and Korea play more
video games and we do it and they don't do this as much.
It starts to breath.
Bend your mind like what it,
what is it exactly about America that has all these shootings all the time and
why so often?
Yeah.
Why?
I think nationalism is a bad thing,
but nationalism in the case where everybody bands together and everybody's nicer
to each other because you're also all fellow Israelites.
What'd you call yourself?
An Israelite if you live in Israel or is that like an Israeli?
One of the black is really,
I remember those guys in black Israelites.
Those guys are a trip that was like,
guys are awesome.
Did you ever see those guys in New York?
Yeah,
I've seen them.
You know what's interesting about them in Israel,
a bunch of the move to Israel and Israel lights are basically just a group of
black people from Chicago that decided they were the true Jews and that real
Jews weren't Jews.
And they were just,
I didn't,
apropos of what I don't know.
And they wear outfits like Superhero,
straight up suits of armor.
And they stand on the corner and say that like,
like white people are the devil
read on brother seat on a group of a move to Israel.
And they were just sort of squatting in Israel.
They just went to Israel and then they just stayed.
And the Israeli government,
the way that the Israeli government immigration works is that you have to be a
Jew to immigrate there.
Uh,
or you know,
or it's complicated.
But if you're a Jew,
it's like automatic citizenship in Israel.
And so they went to these black Israelites and they were like,
okay,
you guys got to,
you guys are like just here,
we can't just move here is Jews only now we are Jews brother.
And they were like,
no,
we'll need you to convert if you're going to stay as citizens.
And they're like,
we you convert brother.
And then Israel basically was just like,
uh,
you know what?
Okay,
you guys can stay.
And they just get them Israeli citizenship as to they never did anything.
And currently you can go to like a weird commune in the middle of Israel and
there's a bunch of American black Israeli Israelite Jews.
Really?
So they just decided to let him stay.
Why they do that?
Because it was just annoying.
I think they were just too,
they were just like forget it.
Let them stay.
It's amazing that they let him stay though.
I know.
It's very weird.
I would think everybody else has to convert because it's total Jewish state.
So like if Brian wanted to move over there,
he'd have to take Hebrew lessons.
And he'd have to convert.
That's right.
And with all that Viking and he's got,
it probably wouldn't work out anyway.
But isn't marijuana legal over there?
I don't think so.
Although there is a marijuana legalization party in parliament,
I think it's why did I think that the law.
Okay.
Let's see.
Is Marijuana legal in Israel?
Yeah.
Maybe not legal,
but very loose with her or changing laws
that could be.
I know that there was a member of parliament,
those from the legalization party
legality of cannabis by country in Wikipedia.
New Insights on mayor marijuana.
Hmm.
Apparently they're,
they're loosening the,
they're,
they're looking at it and they were recognizing the,
uh,
the medical benefits of it.
So,
um,
there's a government approved medical marijuana farm in the Galilee hills of
northern Israel.
What's the Galilee hills?
The Galilee.
The Sea of Galilee is where Jesus walked on water.
Oh Shit.
What a good place to grow weed.
That's probably why they saw him walking on water.
One strain is said to have the strongest psychoactive effect of any cannabis in
the world.
A Jews,
powerful Jews.
That's what we do.
We'll do you know that the reason why Moses supposedly met God when he saw the
burning Bush,
they think that the burning Bush was the Acacia Bush.
They acacia bushes,
rich and DMT,
like one of the richest plants and DMT.
So they think that what it really is is some sort of a metaphor for him taking
this,
this psychoactive drug and having this experience with God like this is like
mainstream Jerusalem scholars are trying to sense.
Totally makes sense,
but all the stories in the Bible are all translated down from ancient Hebrew
originally.
Then to Roman Latin,
rather Greek,
all these different languages that you lose a little bit of the,
the actual original meaning of it.
Right.
The guy's talking to a burning Bush and seeing God and this Bush that's
everywhere.
The Bush spoke to him.
Yeah.
I mean,
come on,
I could give you a bunch of those peaks you.
Yeah,
totally.
It's right now.
You can get it in 2014 that's the,
what's your name?
I am what I am.
That sounds straight up like a high person.
Well that's part of what's going on with a lot of these new churches where they
uh,
have Iowasca as a religious sacrament and it's approved by the Supreme Court.
These are native American or these are white people in Topanga Canyon,
Brazil,
actually two of them from Brazil.
Um,
here I'll pull it up.
Brazilian churches that uh,
I think it's sent diamond or something.
Churches allowed to use psychoactive drug [inaudible].
MMM.
And the uh,
the idea is that look,
if you have wine and wine is the Sacramento a recognized religious,
the freedom of religion in this country should protect our,
our,
our religious sacrament.
And then our religious sacrament is Iowasca and that um,
these,
these guys have these,
these churches fuck the fucking Brazilian Iowasca churches.
Yeah.
There's,
there's a couple of different ones.
Anyway,
the point being that,
I mean that's probably what the fuck was going on when Moses was around,
you know,
if there really was a Moses and he didn't have this experience and what it,
what was their experience told them to be nice to people.
It gave them a list of rules.
The human being should follow base based on morals and ethics that he learned
from a burning plant.
But it also said not to fuck his neighbor's wife.
So that doesn't feel as he said don't covet,
which is really weird because we covet means is that your neighbor's wife,
his property and that you're,
you're coveting her property like you want to and that's a good way to be a
neighbor man.
I mean,
don't,
don't try to fuck your friends wife because you're going to ruin their
relationship.
You know,
if you're one of those creepy dudes like could you imagine if you were living
next door to some dude who looked a lot like David Hasselhoff in his prime in
the 1980s,
and uh,
this fucking David Hasselhoff cap coming over the house while you were at work,
ringing the door bell,
taking your wife out to lunch and all this kind of shit and you're like,
this motherfucker trying to fuck my wife and it just becomes a huge God damn
problem.
I don't see David Hasselhoff said,
nice guy and we're friends and that's it.
I'm like,
listen,
you crazy pitch.
This guy is trying to fuck you.
He's gonna ruin this whole thing.
See that's in the Bible.
David Has David Hasselhoff.
I'm not saying David Hasselhoff.
I mean I'm sure David Hasselhoff,
a beautiful human being.
What I'm saying is if you say,
if you looked like Brian,
for instance,
handsome fellow,
average gluten guy.
This guy right there,
Brian right there.
No regular guy.
Wait,
I'm trying to figure out what you were saying.
Handsome.
Beautiful.
Look at them.
I'm trying to fat
and he's married to some hottie and then this fucking David Hasselhoff looking
motherfucker with a body like the rock.
So the next door trying to take his girlfriend out.
You would be,
you wouldn't be happy with that with you.
That's why I have a drop cam.
I'm checking my checkout right now.
Cleaning and living.
Fuck a checking out.
You're watching.
You're watching a relationship unfold.
Yeah,
he's watching David Hasselhoff banging her over a self.
How is he,
cause he got one of those nights of this total CEO thick roly polies.
Let's
see.
I want to find out about these black Israelites in,
I've seen him out here only once.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
They're in their New York and Chicago.
I've seen him event,
this is where they would go.
Yeah.
Seems about right.
They would read out of the Bible about the so called Jew,
you know the show called Jews today.
Right.
So they have this idea where the 13 tribes of Israel were,
were basically like native Americans,
Mexicans,
Asians,
black people,
Mex,
uh,
you know,
bubble Eskimos,
et,
and then the Jews aren't Jews.
The only people that didn't make it as Jews or Jews,
it just doesn't seem fair.
Well,
you familiar with,
uh,
the Ethiopian Jews?
I,
yeah,
I know about them.
Yeah.
That's where they believe the Ark of the covenant is.
Right.
And you know,
what's weird about that is that it actually could be there.
It's not probably,
why say not probably.
Well,
do you know the,
the entire religion of Easter,
of Ethiopian Orthodox Christianity is based upon the idea that the Ark of the
covenant is in Addis Ababa,
in the main church of the Ethiopian church.
But it's in a special room.
Anytime it's special room and special dude,
who's the only dude that can see it.
I start,
that's when I started going gray a little bit.
So there's a special room with a special dude and only one dude can see it.
Nobody else can see it.
And then when the special dude is ready to retire,
he fought.
He picks another special dude.
And that special dude becomes a guy that can see it,
but the people can never see it.
So I,
whenever I hear things like that,
I start going like that.
That's not real.
You was rightly should.
But imagine if it actually was a special dude and he was only allowed to tell
one of the special dude when he's dying.
They said,
uh,
Graham Hancock got into that.
It's one of the first things that he sort of researched and he researched it
because all these guys that were around that area had cataracts.
Like these,
uh,
these guys that were taking care of that church,
I guess you'd call the monks or whatever low they were saying that,
oh,
I guess they would be,
yeah,
they'd be priests.
Ethiopian cat,
the Christian priests of some sort.
Yeah,
they,
there was quite a few that had had a issues that could be described as similar
to issues that people have when they have radiation poisoning.
So the light of the Lord was so overwhelming that it give them cataracts have
covered in this.
If the Ark of the covenant is a real thing,
like what could it possibly be where if you look at it,
you melt,
you know,
like remember Raiders of the lost Ark,
what could it be?
I wouldn't say flying Nazis.
Right.
Ghost of Nazis today.
It seems like the most likely solution bucketed Nazi Dick's.
Yeah.
Rotten now.
I think if it,
if it is anything that makes any sense at all.
It could be some sort of a reactor.
Like some sort of a home reacted.
Maybe that kid that got arrested recently,
he was making a fucking reactor in his backyard.
Remember that?
I remember that.
Yeah.
So you think that's the arc of the covenant?
I don't know.
I wonder,
I wonder if it really was a such a thing.
See,
they're finding out now pretty assured,
like with a high rate of probability that there's been some massive cataclysmic
disasters that have all but wiped out the human race a couple of times that
they've been thousands and thousands and thousands of years ago.
And if that is the case,
it might very well be that human beings had reached a very high level of
technological sophistication.
And that might be why there were all these beautiful,
enormous,
ancient stone structures that we really don't understand how they,
they made today,
that it could be that there was people
at one point in time,
whether it's 15,000 years ago,
whatever it was,
that had gotten pretty,
pretty sophisticated and a lot of ways,
and then we're almost wiped out by asteroids.
So there'd been enlightenments before our current enlightenment.
Yeah.
And maybe even different,
which is why they have all these incredible stone structures,
but we've seen no evidence whatsoever that they have electricity.
No evidence whatsoever outside of a few batteries that we found.
They have found batteries real.
Yeah.
They found batteries in Iraq here.
Pull up Brian,
pull up an ancient battery,
uh,
Iraq because Iraq is Sumir and Sumir is the,
as far as we know,
like current history,
the oldest known civilization,
the Fertile Crescent.
Yeah.
So that's,
that's exactly where Baghdad is exactly where this,
this civilization was.
That was the first written language that we know of.
The first mathematics.
Yeah,
there's the battery.
It's an actual battery that they've figured out.
I mean,
that is what it is.
That whatever it is,
it generates electricity in a very primitive way.
So what,
what might mean where you beat somebody up in Baghdad?
No,
I thought it meant when you make a really good chicken with a thick crust.
The,
um,
I like that battery.
Yeah.
The,
the idea is that whatever had happened,
they believe like 10,500 years ago was also responsible for the decline of the
ice age.
That it stopped the ice age,
massive global climate change.
But also I'll just talk complete reset of human civilization.
So that's all we're going towards now with global warming.
Kobe,
he's another reset.
Could be,
well this guy had this guy,
Randall Carlson on who's an expert in these,
uh,
geological events and what he described is so much scarier than global warming.
When he describes global cooling,
he's like,
everyone's terrified of global warming and global warming obviously is going to
have plenty of unique problems.
He's like,
what I worry about more than that is the particulates that were released into
the atmosphere,
like coal burning.
He goes,
I worry about that more than,
more than the warming itself.
The warming itself is definitely problematic.
He's not like downplaying it,
but he's saying,
but global cooling,
that's what you wear.
Glasses and smoke lucky strikes and just hang out on the corner.
Man,
now he's talking about ice ages.
He's like,
ice ages are horrific.
That's what kills everybody.
That's what fucks up society.
That's what causes lifespans to be drastically shortened.
That's what causes massive diseases.
That's what causes huge glaciers to just fill up entire continents.
They know now that at least from 10,500 you know,
11,000 years back,
at least half of North America was under a mile high sheet of ice and it Canada,
Canada was all ice.
That's a wall.
The Wall.
Do you know what's game of Thrones?
Oh is like the wall.
It's the wall somewhere.
Yeah,
winter is coming.
Yeah.
And winter lasts forever bro.
But that is actually the,
the world that gave him a throne slips in.
They have these hundred year,
winter.
Yes.
So maybe it's just an ice age.
Well they said that there were times in human history recorded times where
summer never came.
You know,
where they had these mini ice ages would,
they had temperature variance.
You know,
when we think about the variation between winter and summer,
you know in some places you talk about 50 below zero to 50 degrees.
Like that's about as warm as it gets.
It's sort of shift and sometimes it would not shift.
It would just,
it would be just suck.
You would get suck from the jump all year round constantly.
And that's a weird thing to think about that global warming is preferable to
this global cooling and that global cooling is the worst fucking thing you could
ever have happened.
Are we headed towards another ice age?
Is that what that guy said?
No,
no.
He said we're definitely warming up,
but he said,
but there's a lot of factors.
He said that,
you know,
he,
he was talking about co two in the atmosphere and he,
and one of the things that he said that was interesting,
he's like,
see co two in the atmosphere is awful,
but it,
it's also responsible for plant growth.
And the forests have actually started to increase,
increase your amount of,
of growth of a,
of plants and trees because of the fact that like the like PR,
like predicted growth of certain forests is actually much higher than it was
predicted because the co two in the atmosphere,
he said the real issue is there's a lot of other things going on as far as like
solar activity,
the mag fear,
like all these things have to be taken into account.
When you talk about like why the earth gets warmer and colder and there's been
periods,
observable periods from studying ice cores over tens of thousands of years,
it show all these different shifts.
So he said,
yeah,
without a doubt we're,
we're assholes and we're ruining the earth.
And you know,
we're,
we're definitely fucking things up.
But the scariest thing isn't even that.
The scariest thing is that natural disasters like asteroidal impacts,
which are,
they're finding with the latest data that they're far more frequent than,
than we ever thought that meteor impacts on earth are way,
way,
way more frequent.
And that,
like this thing that happened over Russia recently when they saw that what
people drive in their car and these things fucking exploded in the sky.
They're like,
if it exploded,
just,
you know,
whatever it was quarter mile,
lower,
you know,
and,
and on the ground it would have been a massive casualties like thousands of
people dead,
like a nuclear bomb.
Right?
And he's like,
these things are going to happen.
They happen all the time.
We live in a shooting gallery.
All you have to do is look at the moon.
The moon doesn't have any plants or water on it.
So you get to see all the impact holes.
Like that shit can hit hit us too.
Why hasn't it?
It has,
that's what you're saying.
It's just,
it's a perspective about time.
It's a perspective thing.
It's all like we were talking about with these all,
there's so much evil in the world.
There is a lot of evil in the world,
but there's also a lot of people in the world and in perspective,
not that much evil.
Right.
And what he's saying is that the asteroid impacts are inevitable and they're
deadly and they're ruthless.
We just haven't had one in a couple thousand years,
so we're kind of slipping and it could happen literally at this exact incident
all the time.
Yup.
Just boom.
And if it did,
if one of these five mile wide
chunks of iron going 45,000 miles an hour,
it would be seven miles deep into the planet a second after impact.
But what about my career?
But my head shots make,
I needed to get a pilot season is so depressing.
Everyone you know is,
yeah,
the entire ocean gets hit and just everything has gone to ocean disappears and
vanishes.
It does put everything in perspective.
You know,
you think you're at rock bottom,
driving down an alley,
trying to get a blow job from a racist through Compton,
a giant racist
living underneath the bridge of racism,
exacting a toll.
And then,
and then as you're in the middle of your own little interpersonal,
like rock bottom,
a fucking literal rock hits the bottom of the earth and destroys all mankind.
And if that doesn't happen,
the earth itself fucks up.
There's huge meteors that,
that hit the planet and wipe things out,
but they're nothing in comparison to super volcanoes,
super volcanoes.
I fuck up all the time.
They're all over the planet.
There's a bunch of these gigantic calderas.
They get to be the size of mountains and then they explode and all that's left
is a crater and the sun is going to burn out,
is not going to let her get all of this.
The Sun's going to go and just like burn out.
Like one day we're going to go to turn the light switch on in our bedroom and
it's not going to be there no more son,
bitch.
He used it all up.
That's it.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's going to take some time,
but hopefully we'll figure out space travel before that.
Hopefully we'd be like the highway men.
Do you ever hear that song?
Was Willie Nelson Johnny Cash?
No,
I don't know.
Merle haggard and someone else to some the guy,
the highway men,
they uh,
they made it.
Oh,
uh,
who's the guy?
Chris Christopherson.
He's in it too,
I think.
And the sounds are happening song,
great song.
But it's about,
you don't like black dick either.
Maybe they love it until they dress in black all the time.
But it was a,
it's a,
it's a song.
Yeah,
about reincarnation.
You know,
coming back and doing it all over and over and over again.
this,
this notion that whatever life that you live,
you will,
you will continue and you will keep doing it over and over and over and over and
over and over and over again until you get it right.
But along the way,
parallel universes will exist where the next generation will exist and the next
generation will learn from this and go on and on and on.
But you might be stuck here,
right here forever living this very same life over and over again thinking one
day we're going to have flying cars,
Eh,
one day you're going to die and come back and it's going to be 1975 again.
Fuck this is straight up.
Like do it all over and you're all diverse theory.
It's multiverse theory combined with groundhog day combined with some of the
heroes of country music in this country.
Wait,
but I was a highway man.
Have you heard of the Boltzmann brain theory?
What does that,
this is really fucked up.
This is a theory that basically,
um,
because time is,
uh,
you know,
infinite,
right?
So
there's an infinite amount of time ahead of us,
right?
That it is possible that we're currently here existing in reality,
but because there's so much time,
uh,
what eventually will happen is that the sun will burn out,
the universe will keep expanding.
We'll all be pulled apart into nothingness.
There'll be nothing,
but you know,
the atoms will separate from each other and we'll be just floating.
Nothing this time ceasing to exist.
But because there's so much time in,
in front of us that and because there is still some heat and temperature that
eventually,
because all things will happen in an infinite times time frame,
you know what I mean?
If you have enough time at all of the things that are possible to happen in time
will happen because of infinite time that eventually we will recreate,
there'll be a little blip of recreation,
of energy and uh,
you know,
uh,
a virus will be created and then a protozoal be recreated and then a human will
be recreated and then the society will be recreated into the realm of reality
that we're in now.
So all things will happen because there's infinite time,
but because of the realities of energy and,
and,
and production that,
that it is much more likely that a,
and much more,
it takes much less energy to have created a reality where all of our brains,
where this brain that you have Joe,
that is created,
this podcasting empire was created with intact.
It's much more,
uh,
much less energy to create your brain with all of its memories implanted in it
than it is to create a university,
create that informed all of your memories.
Does that make sense?
So for your brain to just have popped up in this universe,
having a bunch of things that it considers to be memories in this considering to
be your,
you know,
this looking like your podcasting studio and your California in your world,
it's much less energy to create a brain that understands that reality than it is
to create an entire history that your brain will have memories of it.
In other words,
it's easier to create a memory of a photo then to create the reality of the past
where the photo was taken.
Does any of this make sense?
No.
Okay.
Well,
I'm not a physicist,
so that could be part of our problem
to create a memory and artificial memory meeting.
Basically it's easier to life.
It's easier for life to be simulation than it is for life to be real.
That's right.
That it's more according to the laws of physics,
it's more likely that all of this is,
this is a simulation where all of our memories are just were created in a,
in a vacuum because it creates,
it takes more work to create a history than it does to create the memory of a
history.
See,
I think that's,
maybe it may be,
who knows?
It might be true.
Might be possible,
but I think that's part of the problem with intellectual masturbation.
Yeah.
Is that you,
you can get into these.
It's more likely that this is not real,
that it Israel,
well,
I've got news
for everybody that's open.
It's not real.
It's fucking real knock knock.
It's real.
Whether it's real in a simulation or whether it's real,
it goes back to the same thing.
It's about having psychedelic experiences.
Are they real or are they hallucination?
Right.
It really doesn't matter whether it's real in the sense that you can put it in a
bag and throw it on a scale and they'll show you a waste 30 pounds or whether
it's real and that you're eyes saw it and then you had a,
a vivid memory of it still real.
Right.
So whether or not your,
your life and your memories are real because they were somehow or another
created in some sort of a simulation or whether they're real because you went
through it.
And because we really did evolve from protozoas the climbed out of the slime and
then it,
all of this was created by asteroidal impacts,
you know,
the theory of Panspermia taking the building blocks of life from other planets
and slamming them into the oceans.
Either way,
it's still real.
It's still real.
I Dunno.
I Dunno if it all really happened.
It doesn't matter if it happened,
whether it really dinosaurs they have bones.
Seems like it was real.
Well,
that's what this guy was saying.
This physicist to,
I was hearing talk about the Dr. Sean Carroll,
that's the guy's name,
was talking about this Boltzmann brain theory.
Uh,
he's like,
that's the most likely scenario that physics has come up with and it's absurd
and no one believes it because it's so crazy.
So they don't even,
so basically if you get to a level with physics where you start getting out into
the,
into time and space,
like the furthest reaches,
you get to a place where you just go,
oh,
it turns out we have absolutely no idea what's going on for now for now.
But I think there's also the theory that makes it tremendous amount of success
that if we do eventually come up with some sort of an augmented reality or
artificial reality,
that it will continue to progress technologically,
there'll be more,
more efficient,
it'll be more complete,
and it will eventually get to a point where it's indistinguishable.
You were,
you're going to have some sort of an oculus rift type reality that's
indistinguishable from the reality that we have right in front of us right here,
that they're going to have a way to stimulate the parts of your body that get
your dick hard because the 250 pound fat checks going to meet you in an alley.
I'm so cold.
I was like,
oh,
you're not cold.
There is no cold.
That might be part of the whole thing that one day that's going to be an option
and then even mental illness is going to be an option in this artificial reality
that we've created or maybe the,
the artificial reality will take into account all the lessons that you can learn
from the failures of others.
So CNN in this artificial reality will be filled with mass murders and crimes
and all these things.
Well,
you could see the horrific reactions in the face of the families of the victims
and all this stuff.
It could be programmed into the thing.
Well,
yeah,
or the fact,
or what if the sun burnt out a billion years ago and somebody right before it
burnt out,
created a computer simulation that could make society keep going on.
And we're just,
we're,
we're in it.
We're just,
we're contained in some ad Menttium marble hurling through the universe,
the speed of light and will slam into an ocean on the other side of the galaxy.
And that ocean will be just like that scene and what it was,
it was the fucking new alien movie.
Promethium the engineer spills his DNA into the river.
We could be about to be promethium engineered DNA sperm.
Dude,
you're a stoner without the weed.
That's what you are.
You're sitting here having stoner thoughts and you don't even use him.
We'd,
that's ridiculous.
I need to go to Peru and meet Gandalf,
man.
You might,
I might need to.
I just don't want,
you know,
imagine,
imagine like what we tell them to go and then
come on,
man.
I'm not doing good man.
Please man.
This is your idea,
man.
Just let me get like $100 real quick.
I'm good for a baby.
You know me or worse.
We're on our way to downtown La to do the ace theater on the August 1st.
Me and Joey Diaz.
And who is that walking down the street with all the zombies?
It's Moshe Chi.
Zip My little,
my little portal.
Hey Joe.
Well,
you have a zipper.
Yeah,
right.
Isn't a lot of those guys with the fucking refrigerator boxes.
I'm about to eat my one meal of the week and Joey Diaz comes over and says,
that's my sandwich.
Listen,
you're already skinny.
I don't even need this.
We need this aggravation.
Yeah.
I don't know Matt.
Yeah,
it's a personal decision,
but I would give you as a suggestion now is to do the natural route first.
Have you ever done isolation tanks?
I have.
What'd you think about it?
I hated it.
Really drove me crazy.
Ooh,
I was thinking about you actually because I knew that you were a proponent,
a proponent of it,
and I really wanted to love it,
but I just,
maybe I'm too anxious maybe.
Which to do it in Portland.
Huh?
It didn't get me high.
It got me anxious.
Did you only do it once?
I did it once.
Yeah.
It's something you got to get used to.
The first time I ever did it,
I was a little weirded out by it for awhile.
I,
it's hard to relax and just accept the fact that you're in this tank and you're
going to move at all.
You start getting busy work where you like,
you start itching for no reason.
Like if you want to scratch your face,
how often is your fucking face?
Itchy.
Almost never.
Like when we're having a conversation.
Besides that time where I faked it,
I didn't have any itchy face.
I didn't,
I mean sometimes I'll rub my hand,
but I don't need to write.
When you're in that tank,
it feels like you need to fuck,
I need to scratch my eyebrows.
What?
I mean,
it's a trip.
How often do you think about your body?
I mean,
you may be more than most people would take a pill.
I'm body all day sun.
I do too.
I think about your body constantly,
which is why I was so happy to come to,
yeah,
I don't,
I don't know what it is about all those signals that go down to your body that
are hard to ignore when you just lie there still.
But it's hard to lie still.
It's very hard a lot still.
Did you see that thing?
We talked about this on the podcast before in 1983.
How they,
this group of people experimented.
They wanted to cut all senses off,
like,
like sight hearing,
you know,
everything.
So they found somebody that was like,
like he had no will to live anymore.
They,
they,
they took his side,
his ways hearing and stuff like that and he was just pretty much had no census
coming in.
So he's pretty much done like an isolation tank.
And he started hearing like dead family members and his head and went to the
point where he just started going crazy saying that they won't stop talking to
me.
And uh,
then he ended up starting to like,
like tearing up,
uh,
pieces of his skin.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
Are you sure this isn't a hoax?
Because there was a hoax though.
Oh,
I know.
Yeah.
I remember that Russian thing.
This is,
I wonder if this is the same.
Well,
it sounds like a crazy person.
The problem is anecdotal evidence based on one particular case,
like,
you know,
you don't know how fucked up that dude was before they told him to do this.
No,
that is,
you're talking about that weird Russian Snopes story.
Yeah.
I think so.
They came in and it was other,
so it was a vision of nightmarish gruesomeness beyond all of that to anyone had
ever seen before.
Yeah.
It's like,
um,
event horizon,
that movie,
right?
They traveled through a wormhole and they hit the hell and hell gets into their
spaceship and they start telling each other.
Is that what you meant?
You meant they movie event horizon?
Yeah.
I'm just talking about the new guide.
So I think that uh,
what,
what you get out of the tank once,
once you do it,
once you really do do it,
you get out of it and it's an environment where you actually separate from the
impo input that your body is giving your brain and that can be good or that
could be bad depending on how you are with your brain.
Like if you're one of those people that you know,
go back to people that have drug addictions that are just can't wait to get that
fixed and all they're thinking about is getting that crack in them and then try
to get them to lie down in a tank for two hours and think about nothing and
don't move,
they're going to be so uncomfortable.
Right?
They're going to be so freaked out because all their body is just tuned into
responding to this manic mind and running around and doing a bunch of things
like that.
When that guy shot heroin,
did you see that when you hear it,
did you pee?
You said when he was shot heroin and he's jumping up and down and move in and
stuff like this is Bonnie's getting his,
his is crazy fix when you're in that tank,
there's no moving on.
No,
we saw that yesterday.
I was in palm springs yesterday and there was just like 26 year old kid and his
mom was like 60 years old walking along,
but the kid was so obviously fucking gacked out on crystal.
Like he's like moving around and scratching himself in this old white haired
ladies,
like attempting to look and ignore the re.
I mean it's so obvious.
We're sitting at the intersection looking at this guy and she's like,
La,
la La.
We're just having a nice lunch out with Rmr son and he's scratching fucking
tweaking out and shit.
It's just like part bastard poor Bastow does.
Right.
That's a scary one.
Two.
That's one where you just lose all of your ability to make good judgment.
Crystal.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I never did it.
I've done it.
I've done crank.
Was it like,
it's not pleasant for me.
It wasn't pleasant,
but now I think now I'm an artist,
but now I feel like people like us would be like,
I know for sure people like us would be at first have an instant feeling of
like,
I'm so fucking creative,
you know?
And you'd be like,
I'm writing so much.
I've never written so much in my entire life.
And then a month goes by and you're like,
oh my God,
I'm a fucking nightmarish.
Tweaker what's happened?
I'm stuck.
Well,
that's the Adderall thing.
Exactly what he's done.
The Adderall.
Yeah.
I know a couple people that do the Adderall.
A lot of people do it.
There are problems.
They are terrible.
They're,
they're really like,
they're not tuned in very well.
The people around them either.
Have you read math land?
No.
Oh,
that's a good one.
You'd like it.
What is it?
It's basically about how,
uh,
how methamphetamine is like destroying the,
the modern Midwestern small town.
But it describes in pretty great detail what happens to people,
why people get addicted to meth because meth has,
uh,
has a,
a chemical compound.
The way that math gets you high,
it gets you high in a different and more profound way than any other drug.
Like it.
Uh,
it,
it takes the whatever that dopamine,
and I'm not an expert on this,
so I'm not going to say it exactly,
but whatever that dopamine release that regular drugs give you,
it takes that and like doubles it and also at the same time makes it harder for
you to produce the dopamine naturally.
So it makes life worse and the high better at the same time.
So that totally makes sense.
Well,
whenever you ask for more than your body wants to give,
he just force it,
redline it,
force it,
and then you have this backs off and you don't have any afterwards.
You,
your body loses its ability to produce it and so you give it back to it.
It's like that Cadillac Ron guy where he started shooting up and as he's
shooting up,
then all of a sudden he's active and moving around rambling a lot better.
It's still not that good,
but whatever,
it's battle rap.
It's on.
It's not my,
it's not my sport,
but also it's a little weird that heroin would make you,
well,
I'm better.
Like you said,
you should be like,
is laying on the couch.
I said,
you know,
it's bad.
My experience with heroin,
one of the big ones was this guy,
his nickname was water dog,
these calm water dog or buffalo bill and he was a pool player,
high level pool player.
I used to play a lot of pool when I lived in New York and this guy would gamble
and you'd shoot up and he would disappear.
He'd go in the bathroom and shoot up and come out and sit down for like 30
minutes and not move.
Just sit there like this,
just all fucked up on heroin.
Then he would get up and he would play pool so well.
It was incredible where he couldn't miss,
he couldn't miss.
He played perfect.
It was like perfection and you would watch him play and some of the best pool
I'd ever seen in my life.
You know what?
That actually makes sense because his ideal state was an hour after shooting up.
Right.
A moment after shooting up,
he's too high to function,
you know,
uh,
a day after shooting up,
he's getting that flu,
that sickness.
So his ideal,
perfect human state,
a person in that kind of addiction is,
you know,
the high wears down a little bit and he's like a normal person again.
Yeah.
He's a normal person.
And also his nerves were gone.
Right because worries and
fears.
Like he was gambling for a lot of money.
They're planning like tent for like $10,000.
He didn't give a fuck totally.
Again,
didn't give a fuck.
He just couldn't miss it.
Couldn't miss.
And he had no anxiety,
no anxiety and he was playing perfect and peep.
He would start,
the betters would get start complaining,
they would start to make like rules,
but he couldn't shoot up before he played.
There was all this shit cause it's a weird handicap.
Yeah.
They would say like,
look,
you know,
this guy who was playing this Guy George,
the Greek who led this way to talk,
he talked like this,
this motherfucker.
He goes into the fucking bathroom,
he shoots his shit.
He comes out,
he can't miss this cocksucker and he would get get all upset.
Like I'm not playing him.
If he's shooting up,
hey you fucking city.
It's any of it.
The whole time you can't shoot up.
Like they had these legs,
little agreements.
He wouldn't do it crazy.
He wouldn't do it.
Of course not.
That was his medicine.
Yeah.
I met him out here in Compton or are men amount here rather in um,
uh,
Bellflower and he wanted me to take them to Compton to,
um,
is it a pool tournament and want to,
to drive them in and to go get his heroin.
I was like,
Bitch,
I'm not driving you in a fucking Compton.
You out of your mind.
You could've gotten a great blowjob I here,
but you'll also could get your car taken away.
That's true.
Cause if they ever catch you buying drugs,
like the idea is that if you're in a car and you take someone and they're buying
drugs in the cops show up,
they can confiscate your car.
Big Tea.
There's a lot of steal from you,
which is hilarious.
You're doing something you're not allowed to do,
so we're allowed to steal your car.
Take it.
Yeah.
They just take your car and then the,
the government owns it.
The,
what does the government do?
Oh,
they auction at the auction and they take the proceeds and they use it to hire
more cops.
Not Crazy.
It's all just,
and it's all just speaking of computer simulation.
This is all just made up.
Yeah.
I think about the law all the time.
Just like somebody decided that we could have a law.
Actually it was Moses.
Moses saw the burning Bush.
He was like,
well,
we should make law and then all of a sudden you can get your car taken away for
driving water,
dog to get heroin.
I was like,
what?
How did this happen?
Well,
how about places in the country right now,
2014 where it's still illegal to have sex if you're gay.
It's still illegal to have a oral sex,
still legal to have anal sex.
It's sodomy.
They have sodomy laws.
There's still,
I mean,
if somebody wanted to prosecute you for certain sodomy laws,
they still exist in certain parts of the country.
That's why I embarked on my new tour,
uh,
sodomy busters.com and where I'm going to all the sodomy law states and I'm
engaging in hardcore passive sodomy with enormous gay men.
That's a good move.
And as long as you're passive,
they can't even say anything.
I've only did was lay there,
give him shit.
I asked him to stop silently,
but he wouldn't do it as long as he did it silently.
You're clear,
your consciousness clear.
Did you weep?
Yeah,
definitely.
I weeped I whooped with joy though.
Yeah.
Sodomy laws,
gay marriage laws,
all of it.
Just anytime there's laws involving things that is a choice and things that some
people like and you don't imagine if there's laws on certain kinds of music.
I mean this is just as ridiculous as laws and certain types of sex.
Like you caring with someone else does that they like to do is pretty weird.
Alistair Crawley was right.
Do as thou wilt.
That is the whole of the law.
Don't hurt anybody else.
That's so satanism.
That's most cashiers going satanism on it.
I mean,
I'm a Jew,
but I got to say,
I,
there's,
I believe do is do what you want.
Everybody said,
well,
morality based laws are ridiculous.
The only thing,
the only thing that makes any sense,
you know what to say they always harp on is protecting children.
So that's what it was.
Don't hurt children don't yet.
But they believe that somehow or another engaging an immoral activity could
somehow influence children or trickle back.
Send the wrong message.
Like one of those crazy hot fox news chicks,
the laws in Colorado.
Do you think this is sending the wrong message to the children?
Meanwhile,
the wrong message is being sent to the children currently by the system we have
in place.
Not just the wrong message,
only wrong messages,
messages or the Ma.
It's like,
well,
we're fucked.
Healthcare's fucked.
You know,
everything costs too much money tax that we need more money from taxes.
Oh,
we're going to war here.
We've got to watch out.
I ran my,
blow us up.
Oh,
Russia is going to blow up Ukraine.
Uh,
it's just the messages are terrible.
The news can't just be a event.
It just,
if you guys are pretending that you're some sort of a moral voice,
if you're pretending that you know,
is this sending the wrong message to the children?
It can't just be events and and points of controversy.
You've,
if you've taken on that responsibility,
then you also have the responsibility since you're broadcasting to millions of
people to somehow or another it luminate certain ideas somehow or another
elevate cultural ideas and give people these,
these possibilities of of of good these possibilities of good nature,
of good,
good future of,
of good human behavior instead of the majority of it just being eye catching.
If it bleeds,
it leads bullshit.
There's a lot going on that's good and nobody hears about it.
There's a lot going on.
That's great.
There's a lot of beauty in the world and you're concentrating continually on
negative.
The perspective is that if it's negative,
then somehow or another,
it's important to know the news as we get it.
It's important to know,
but it's just as important to know about all these positive things,
if not more important.
When you look at this 7 billion,
300 million in this continent,
you look at this,
this country rather,
this like perspective of like good shit to bad shit.
Well,
you're getting on the news.
He's not balanced at all.
It's not fair and balanced.
You fucking assholes are concentrating almost entirely on the bad shit.
You're concentrating almost entirely on nonsense when it comes to like marijuana
laws and sending message to the children.
That's seconds that you wasted actually saying that you fucked America.
You hate America with your shitty choices and how you projected.
Thanks.
Well,
it's like a terrorism.
You know the idea of what terrorism is.
It's like you were saying,
a few people do a terrible thing,
but most people aren't doing a terrible thing.
Yeah,
but terrorism,
it's goal is not to create damage,
but to create terror,
to make people afraid to go out.
Even though all they did was blow up one school bus.
Now everybody's afraid to send their kids to school on the bus.
Well,
the news is doing the same thing.
It's just,
you know,
it's just doing that over the over mass media airwaves.
It's like creating a small amount of terror so that everybody's afraid all the
time.
Or if you want to go
full on Alex Jones,
then you say what the news is actually doing is reporting these instances and
these instances are in fact designed to keep people scared and keep the military
industrial complex in a position where they can demand massive amounts of money
because they have to protect you from these horrific events that happen
incredibly rarely.
But we need almost all of your money all day long to stop them from happening.
And the only reason why they're not taking place every day like fucking popcorn
in the microwave just pop up pop up because because of the good men and women of
this government to protecting you from the horrible realities of terrorism.
I believe that except that I believe that it's even scarier than that,
which is that there's no diabolical man behind the curtain.
It's like,
it's like a robot that we've created a consciousness robot that we've created
and even the people that are perpetuating that believe that it's the truth.
So there's no one to say,
hey,
this is crazy.
We have to stop.
Cause everybody on every level of the stratosphere believes that we're engaged
in something necessary and good and proper.
Yeah.
Well that's like when people talk about television programming and they go,
well you know,
television programming is designed to make people stupid.
They get together and they think about,
well I can tell you for a fact that's not true.
How can I tell you?
Because I hosted fear factor or if anybody was doing something designed to make
people stupid,
it's fucking fear factor.
And I hosted that shit for 148 episodes and that's not what it is.
What it is is people like stupid shit.
Right?
So if you make something really stupid,
it's sells.
And if it sells,
everybody makes money.
And that's why it was created 100% to all conspiracy theories.
Throw him out the window when it comes to that.
There's no government agencies that come to the set and say,
you guys are making this show too fucking smart.
We need a dumb,
if we don't have a dumb,
we're not going to have enough soldiers.
We don't have enough soldiers.
This fucking country is going to melt.
That doesn't happen.
No guy shows up with a fucking white crew cut and a cigar.
You know,
like looking like some military guy from a Spiderman comics
book.
But the reality that you're talking about is scarier because when there is a
white crew cut guy,
then the people can realize what's happening and overthrow them.
They can take them out.
That's right.
Spider man can come save the day.
There's no Spiderman that's going to save the day.
It's the spider web like consciousness raising that we all gain
by hour indulgence in Ibogaine.
That would certainly help.
No,
but it is.
Eventually we're just going to have to either wake up or go to sleep completely.
Well,
there's a reality that not everyone's going to play that game.
So if you did have some sort of a psychedelic revelation,
if you did have a whole country that had embraced these new ideas and had tried
to turn the,
the current culture that we have today into a more peaceful,
more self aware,
more sustainable culture,
still got to deal with Africa and he's still got a deal with Iran,
you still got to deal with Russia with all these parts of the world that may or
may not be playing that game,
but you're hopeful.
Yes,
I am.
You were hopeful.
Yeah,
for sure.
Without a doubt and things could go terribly wrong at any point in time along
this hopeful,
but I,
I think I'm hopeful that we'll rebuild after that.
Look,
I think that Yellowstone might blow up and kill everyone on this fucking
continent.
It's very possible.
That's a continent killer.
If that does happen.
Yellowstone,
what about Jelly stone?
That's not real.
That's Yogi.
Yogi,
Yogi.
That could blow at any moment.
There could be a big picnic basket.
Is that not true?
No.
Why is Yellowstone?
I'm going to kill us all.
Yellowstone,
they discovered in the early two thousands as a called Dara volcano that's 300
miles wide that at one point in time Yellowstone was like a mountain and the
mountain blew up a 300 mile wide mountain blew up and filled the sky with
fucking molten lava and nuclear winter and kills everything in the continent.
It happens every 600 to 800,000 years.
It's going to happen again.
And the last time it happened was 600,000 years ago.
Oh my God,
that's the most terrible thing I've ever heard in my life.
And isn't it funny like the moment that it blows everyone on earth while
simultaneously just go,
oh,
Islam,
Christianity,
capitalism,
socialism,
gun control and sanity,
rape culture,
my career,
my girlfriend,
my personal.
It'll just be like,
oh,
none of it mattered.
And then we're all dead.
It's just like an immediate like consciousness raised where everybody just goes,
oh,
it was all about the volcano this whole time.
But for that moment,
that will be from the moment before it kills you or if you're unlucky for the
moment.
If you're like in Maryland and it takes a long time to kill you,
that's the straight into having sex,
right?
What would you do?
I don't think you'd get it up.
I guarantee your kid,
you're not going to get it up.
If the sky is filled with molten ash,
oh my God,
are we dead immediately?
Most likely.
California is fucked.
It's just not that far.
There's like a death zone.
There's a death zone that's like several states over and then there's like the
east coast,
the Far East Coast,
which you know they're going to be dealing with zombies.
They're going to have to put fences up because people were just going to be half
molten,
wandering through the fucking desert on the way to New York.
It's going to be fucked and there'd be nothing growing.
The climate will change the whole,
the whole country will cool.
That's what I've been talking about that a lot.
That notion that like there we won't do anything,
especially as it relates to global warming.
We won't do anything until it is too late because it being too late will be the
evidence that we all need that will,
that will motivate us to do something.
Yeah.
I don't think that there's anything they can do.
They say that if they stopped carbon emissions right now,
if everyone just stopped burning coal and stop driving cars and cows stopped
farting,
there's still,
the process is like almost inexorably begun the process of at least getting to a
certain point of warming and not just warming but,
but the massive shifts in the,
the,
the like the differences between,
it was like cold and warm that the weather become more volatile,
storms become more frequent.
They're like almost nothing they could do about that at this point in time.
Can I just do what I want with impunity and just say super volcano at the end of
every behavior?
No,
because then if you become some epic Gingiss con con and then the future
remembers you is that there isn't a future them off,
but it's going to be a future for people in Australia.
Don't make it.
We should all move to Australia.
That's the move.
If,
if,
if Yellowstone starts rambling,
I'm living in Sydney Bitch.
I love it over there.
What makes you think you'll be able to get on a flight to Sydney?
Cause I'm like one of them dogs that runs from tsunamis,
Bro.
I'm in tune with the mother nature.
It was just like fucking,
I just,
I'll be in my tank and I'd be like telling my family it's time to go to
Australia.
So the moment Fox News pipes on in world news tonight there is lots of death and
murder.
But first a story from Yellowstone national park and a bit of rumbling
underneath America's favorite part.
You decide,
do you know they have thousands of earthquakes in Yellowstone every year?
Thousands.
I really don't like this.
It's just a matter of time.
It is a matter of time.
But it might be a hundred thousand years,
might be 200,000 years.
That's a long fucking time.
But it literally might be today.
It could be soon.
We'll think.
They would know,
they'd have good indications that some activity was going on.
But I think it would be like one of those movies where,
you know,
one of those fucking Armageddon type movies where there would be one scientist
who had figured out but no one would believe him.
And he'd be yelling and he would get arrested cause he'd break into the TV
studio.
You know,
we need a wine people.
Y'alls tone is kind of blow and they pull them out and it's a,
who would it be?
Bradley Cooper,
maybe Bradley Cooper.
They didn't handcuff him and he screaming,
you were all going to die and then we all die and then you would be driving just
driving on the left hand side.
That's all you have to do.
But how do you get there?
Aren't all the flights going to be full?
Getting a boat?
You got to get on a boat,
a really quick boat and get there quickly.
No,
it would take forever.
You have to fucking fly.
If it takes 16 hours at 500 miles an hour and a fucking plane and do the math,
what does that,
that's a lot.
It's many thousands of miles.
It's fucking terrible from here to Australia.
Yeah.
Take 40 days,
something like that.
On a boat.
Yeah,
just saw this like a fat one you beat and each other 22 days.
So this great documentary about this Dutch girl that took a boat around the
world,
just 14 years old,
youngest person ever to do it
by herself.
Her parents are assholes.
No,
they're cool.
They're ass holes and no,
I think they're cool.
They could stick it,
suck it.
Their parents are idiots.
Fucking lit.
A 14 year old.
Go around the world.
She's 14 how about wait until she's 18 because then she wouldn't be the youngest
person to do it.
So fucking stupid.
She did it though.
Good.
Who Cares?
I've been around the world too.
I don't want any credit for it.
Got in a fucking plane.
Oh,
she did it by boat.
Amazing.
What a person.
I mean,
but according to your own logic though,
who cares if her parents,
I mean the fucking supervolcano man.
No,
because she might live to be a ripe old age and influence people in a very
positive way or get eaten by sharks at 14,
because her parents were fucking retarded and they let her get on a raft and
they pushed her out to the ocean.
We love you,
but float on young soldier
shine on you.
Crazy diamond that she has a hard to do.
I'm sure she's got a book deal or parents are assholes.
They're fucking,
they're probably trying to cash in on her like little beaver parents.
I don't know.
I was thinking watching it,
uh,
like,
you know what,
like w it's not valuable to keep your children alive.
Hold on,
wait for it.
But it's just like every parent keeps her children alive.
But to keeping them alive for what?
Like to give him a true experience of life that's so much more valuable than
just keeping them like their heart beating and them making sure that they're
eating food,
that everybody should do that.
But to make your children have a life that's worth living.
I feel like it's worth risk that my point is like there was this,
uh,
this family who was living on a boat abroad and they had a little baby and then
that was on this last week's episode of this American Life.
They had a baby and they had to call the navy to rescue them cause their boats
started taking on water and everybody was like,
you're the worst parents ever.
Why would you have a baby at see all this stuff?
But it's just like there's so many people having such a regular experience of
life like this,
whoever this baby would have been at [inaudible] and the baby lived,
is it going to have such a more intense and unique experience of life?
Like I don't feel like it's that valuable to have a safety in world where you
know,
you make sure your baby's okay at all moments at all time.
Then to give a kid an experience of a,
of an exciting life.
Well,
I think there's definitely a balance when it comes to risk and reward.
You know,
and I,
I say this as a person who's fought full contact martial arts tournaments.
I've,
I've probably had,
I don't know how many amateur fights I had,
but is over 50 easily.
It was probably a close to a hundred.
I don't know.
I did it for five years,
basically almost every week or constantly.
I was constantly competing and sometimes he'd fight two,
three times in day.
And then all the times that I trained and spark in the gym,
which a lot of them were just basically fights.
I did a lot of risky shit.
So I don't,
I'm not averse to risk,
but the risk of competition,
I believe there's that.
What would I feel about martial arts,
and this is,
I say this was extreme bias,
but I've always said that martial arts are a vehicle for developing your human
potential.
And then in doing something incredibly difficult but getting really good at it,
you develop this intense focus that you could apply to all these other things
and you can see that thing well and find that path,
whether it's in,
you know,
uh,
an art form or anything else that you decided to pursue that learning how to do
a martial art and because it's so difficult and because it's so challenging and
that you learn a lot about learning and you learn a lot about character and
focus that that can be applied to other things.
I don't know if that could be the case about a 14 year old in a fucking boat in
the middle of the ocean that gets eaten by a shark.
I don't know.
I mean,
she got lucky.
She made it.
She got lucky.
She's zig when she could have said,
by the way,
I was watching this fucking animal planet.
What was,
when did the animal planet just start lying to us and around the Mermaid Times?
These motherfuckers have a new one on Megla dawn's.
They have a new one that's so fake.
And I'm watching this and my kids are asking me if they're really our 75 foot
long sharks.
They have this picture of this that they're pretending is a whale and the whale
that's been bitten in half by a shark.
But it's all like a highly detailed computer generated picture.
But as someone who knows with CGI,
looks like I'm looking,
I'm like,
this is bullshit.
And is someone who pays attention to whether or not Megler dawn's actually
exist.
I'm like,
they don't fucking exist.
And then they showed this photo from World War II that shows a giant shark that
was near a u boat and like the fuck it does.
So you're just lying.
Made Up.
Creature eats a complete work of fiction.
Complete work.
Let me pull it up,
cause I know,
I know it is,
but I need to know meg.
Dawn,
a show is fake.
It's total bullshit.
But they don't tell you that you,
you watch it and you think that there's really some sort of a fucking giant
shark out there.
Discovery Channel perverts provokes outrage with fake shark week documentary.
Um,
this is,
yeah.
Mengele dawn,
the monster shark that lives,
it's a completely fake documentary with fake Cgi and everything.
And people or act out in scientists are fucking furious.
Like,
here's the guy who tweeted this.
Uh,
his name is David Schuffman please our tea.
I'm a professional shark scientist and I can unequivocably state that mega don
is extinct and he writes this thing on shark week,
but they have these fake photos.
Oh,
it was once real,
well,
a long time ago,
like millions of years ago.
It was a real shark,
just a big shark.
And they think that the shark went extinct because it fed on enormous whales and
that the sperm whales,
a lot of them might have figured out a way to get away from the sharks by going
into colder water.
So by going into colder water,
the sharks couldn't survive in that water.
And so they managed to live,
but the sharks didn't have enough food and so they went extinct.
It's fucking horrible though,
that they did this because look,
the mermaid thing is like,
you gotta be an asshole if you believe is really mermaids.
You know,
I get it.
If you're really stupid,
it's Kinda mean,
but this megalodon thing is bullshit because it looks real as fuck.
You're,
you're watching these people talk,
they're talking about their experiences.
It seems God damn real.
And they did it all just for ratings.
He's fuck heads.
It's really awful,
man.
It's really gross because you know they didn't,
it's not like there was some new movie piece of shit movie with Shannon Doherty.
Remember Shannen Doherty sure is these killer lampreys but it's obviously a
movie.
It's so stupid.
We're running out of time here.
Three hours and then we turn into a pumpkin.
All right.
Fuck,
fuck the history channel or no discovery channel.
Who is it?
Animal.
Every channel and Anima plantings are owned by John Doherty.
Poor girl.
Fuck a Fox News who killed himself and all those other people out there that
Santa Barbara.
Fuck that fat barrage likes throwing them bonds for racist lady.
But don't fucker just get your Dick Stockton and keep it moving and get all
sweaty and Chile.
Dude,
this is a fun podcast,
man.
I really enjoyed it.
We gotta do it again and come back.
Please follow Moesha on a,
on Twitter.
You can go to his website,
Moshe kasher.com and a when you're going to be,
I'm on the road again.
What's your next gig
again?
There'll be in Fort Lauderdale at the hard rock casino.
And then next week and affiliate Johnny Brenda's.
You can come see me
there.
Oh,
you're doing that?
Um,
the Improv at the hard rock.
Yeah,
that's right.
Places.
Awesome.
That's one of the best places.
Places in the country.
Yeah.
That sad fucking place.
And then the week after that will be at comics.
Choose the two casinos in a row.
So come see me in any of those please.
Yeah,
good times.
You fucks.
All right.
Thanks everybody.
Uh,
thanks to legal zoom.
Use the codeword Rogan and save yourself some money@legalzooms.com
legalzoom.com.
Um,
this weekend,
Friday night,
we are at the Ice House Comedy Club for another episode of Thunderpussy
Thunderpussy.
Like all of the death squad podcast is available on iTunes.
You can go to [inaudible] dot TV [inaudible] dot TV to,
uh,
to go to that,
to,
to download any of those.
And also to buy any of Brian's a kitty cat tee shirts.
You can sell this new one.
Yeah,
I'm going to,
I'm going to read,
do some change.
Some stuff that was like a test shirt.
I guess that's a login test shirt.
This is good.
A lot of get stoked.
It's smooth to is not,
it's just like the other ones.
There's not like a thick sort of a thick,
what are those things called?
Plastic Shell.
Like a silk screen.
Do they,
but on a silk screen,
what are they called when they are numb?
What do they call it?
Uh,
I don't know.
What does that thick film stuff?
When the patch,
it's called a Dukie.
Best to keep pat.
Yeah.
You don't want that dooky path.
Tomorrow morning,
Bert Kreischer 11:00 AM we'll,
we'll be here with,
uh,
with the fucking the machine.
Let's see if he starts drinking at 11:00 AM uh,
thanks to [inaudible] dot com go to o,
n n I.
T use the Code Word Rogan and save 10% off any and all supplements are right.
You dirty freaks.
We'll see you soon.
Much love big kiss to all.
I'm Luma.
Luma.